Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 38, SIMD. Take it away, Patrick. We're going to start off here, Episode 38, with a question from a viewer. Oh, well, we don't have viewers. Listener.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 38 期，SIMD。开始吧，Patrick。我们先从第 38 期开始，回答一位观众的问题。哦，好吧，我们没有观众。是听众。
A listener question. Although today we do have viewers. This is actually the first time we have viewers. Last time we had viewer. But I don't know that it was one of our viewers who asked this question. It was definitely a listener, though. That's a good point. A listener.
一位听众的问题。虽然今天我们确实有观众。这实际上是我们第一次有观众。上次我们有观众。但我不知道是不是我们的观众问的这个问题。不过这绝对是一位听众。说得好。一位听众。
And they asked uh well i should give credit to at least the first name of the person but i don't have it but it's okay you'll know who you are uh the question was do computers ever make mistakes this is a good question uh and uh some people i think this is actually posted in our google plus uh community and so actually someone had written back, and we'll share our own opinions. But one of the things when you first are introduced to computers is you're told,
他们问……嗯，我至少应该提到提问者的名字，但我没有，不过没关系，你会知道你是谁的。嗯，问题是：计算机真的会犯错吗？这是一个好问题。嗯，有些人，我想这实际上是发在我们的 Google Plus 社区里的，所以确实有人回复了，我们会分享我们自己的看法。但当你第一次接触计算机时，你会被告知，
the computer doesn't ever make a mistake. It only does what you tell it to do. And sometimes as programmers, we write bugs or faults. So quick interrupt, the asker was Matthew, I won't say his last name. Actually, his last name is right on G+. It was Matthew Alabastro. Thank you for the awesome question. We love it. broken or wrong um and then the the person who responded actually you know got the thing the same thing that first came to my mind when i read the question which is that there actually is sometimes the processors the thing which are the oh simply the brain of the computer but the thing
计算机从不犯错。它只会做你告诉它做的事。有时作为程序员，我们会写出 bug 或错误。插播一下，提问者是 Matthew，我就不说他的姓了。其实他的姓就在 G+ 上。是 Matthew Alabastro。感谢你提出的精彩问题。我们很喜欢。损坏或错误……然后回复的那个人，其实你知道，和我读到这个问题时想到的第一件事是一样的，那就是有时处理器确实会出错，也就是计算机的大脑，但我们想到计算机时，
that we think about when we think about a computer you're typically thinking about the processor doing the work and it does does sometimes have logic flaws, things that it's supposed to do. And there are several famous ones. But one is that sometimes you have different lines that are supposed to correspond. Like if you do a divide by zero, then that should be a certain kind of error. But sometimes that will be actually triggerable by other stuff or won't get triggered at all. And then this can cause a problem because it means your processor doesn't do the expected behavior um and there's we talked about one i think it was last episode or two episodes ago where it turns out the estimation for pi uh in some of the intel processors isn't as accurate by several like 10 bits or something as it could be and it leads to kind of errors in trigonometric functions
通常会想到处理器在工作，它有时确实会有逻辑缺陷，也就是它应该做的事情。有一些著名的例子。其中之一是，有时你会有应该对应的不同线路。比如如果你做除以零，那应该是一种错误。但有时这实际上会被其他东西触发，或者根本不会被触发。这可能会导致问题，因为这意味着你的处理器没有执行预期的行为。嗯，我们谈到了一个，我想是上一期或上上期，英特尔处理器中对圆周率的估算在某些情况下不够准确，差了大约 10 位左右，这导致三角函数出现了一些错误。
near pi yeah i mean another one i'm just uh there's a link to it uh i'll put a link in the show notes but there's this f div bug in like the 90s with pentium where like they would uh i don't remember this i mean i could read the article but basically it's something to do with like the division like calculating the remainder of the division or something. But but yeah, basically they got it wrong in the processor. And, you know, it just it just means that like there are certain divisions that, you know, you can do them, but it won't give you the answer that that you want it to and uh you know sometimes through some christmas miracle you can like you can solve it in software by changing the firmware of the of the processor and things like that but i mean really you know many times it's just there's nothing that you can
在圆周率附近。是的，我的意思是另一个，我只是……有一个链接，我会把它放在节目说明里，但在 90 年代奔腾处理器上有一个 F div bug，就像他们会……我不记得这个了，我可以读一下这篇文章，但基本上它与除法有关，比如计算除法的余数之类的。但基本上，他们在处理器里算错了。而且，你知道，这只是意味着有些除法，你知道，你可以做，但它不会给你想要的答案。而且，你知道，有时通过某种圣诞奇迹，你可以通过更改处理器的固件等方式在软件层面解决它，但我的意思是，真的，很多时候你对此无能为力。
do about it i mean it's just it's etched it's as if like you know you bought the wrong screwdriver or something right you're just kind of done so but surprisingly sometimes sometimes these bugs you know quote-unquote bugs linger around so like there's some quirk uh that wasn't intended but then if you like a you know if intel has like a quirk in their current line of processors amd is faced with the situation of trying to either replicate the bug or you know fixing it but then having you know compiler of trying to either replicate the bug or, you know, fixing it, but then having, you know, compiler writers trying to determine which processor is being used if they want to work around it, which is why it makes it difficult to fix that software. Yep. And I mean, a lot of this, I mean, there's one thing I didn't realize until I moved to the West Coast.
我的意思是，它就像是刻在上面的，就像你买错了螺丝刀一样，对吧？你只能认栽。但令人惊讶的是，有时这些所谓的“bug”会一直存在。所以，如果英特尔目前的处理器系列中存在某种怪癖，AMD 就面临着要么复制这个 bug，要么修复它，但随后编译器编写者需要确定正在使用哪个处理器，如果他们想绕过它，这就是为什么在软件层面修复它很困难。是的。我的意思是，很多这种情况，有一件事我在搬到西海岸之前没意识到。
There's a ton of cross-pollination. So, you know, there's a ton of, like, Intel people who are at AMD and, you know, AMD people at Google and Google people at Facebook and Facebook, you know there's a ton of like intel people who are at amd and you know amd people at google and google people at facebook and facebook you know what i mean and so um you know obviously you can't just take the technology from one company and give it to the other but it's like if at the end of the day there's like a core group of people and they agree on a way to do floating point and then one of them leaves and goes to amd and he implements almost the exact same way and now you have the same bug on you know 99 of the world's processors i actually thought of this like in a totally different way which is
这里有大量的交叉授粉。所以，你知道，有很多英特尔的人去了 AMD，AMD 的人去了 Google，Google 的人去了 Facebook，Facebook 的人……你知道我的意思吗？所以，显然你不能直接拿一家公司的技术给另一家公司，但如果归根结底有一群核心人员，他们就浮点运算的方式达成一致，然后其中一个人离开去了 AMD，他实现了几乎完全相同的方式，现在你就在全球 99% 的处理器上有了同样的 bug。我其实是以一种完全不同的方式思考这个问题的，
not the common way obviously because uh no one else seemed to think of it this way but also it's like it's very esoteric uh in hindsight but the first thing I thought when I saw this was in the context of like machine learning and things like that like do do computers ever make mistakes like in a sense that do they not do what you want them to do and I think that, like, this is actually, like, kind of interesting. It's really, it's, like, now we're, things are getting kind of very high level with computers. And, I mean, you're doing a lot of, like, statistical analysis and all these, like, stochastic processes and things like that. And it's not really clear um like at some point the computer will start making mistakes like
这显然不是通常的方式，因为似乎没有其他人这样想，但事后看来这非常深奥。当我看到这个问题时，我首先想到的是机器学习之类的背景，比如计算机真的会犯错吗？在某种意义上，它们是否没有做你想让它们做的事？我认为这其实很有趣。现在我们对计算机的理解已经非常高层了。我的意思是，你正在做大量的统计分析和所有这些随机过程之类的东西。而且并不完全清楚……在某种程度上，计算机确实会开始犯错，比如
right now it's like if anything is wrong it's always our fault and in reality like there's always you know you as a programmer can change things and the computer ultimately is supposed to be like reproducible right but uh like we're getting more and more into like crazy ai things robotics things like that and so at some point i mean the computer will be kind of making mistakes i mean that's like i don't know it's if that crossover will ever happen it's kind of so i mean computers can make mistakes in certain ways depending on how you think about it uh besides just we say like um if you get sometimes my credit card i've had a couple times it detect what it thought was fraud right which is some computer there's no person saying they're looking at my credit card history but some computer determines that my current spending habit
现在，如果有什么不对劲，那总是我们的错。实际上，作为程序员，你总是可以改变事情，计算机最终应该是可重现的，对吧？但我们越来越多地进入疯狂的 AI、机器人技术等领域，所以到某个时候，计算机确实会犯错。我不知道这种跨越是否会发生。所以，我的意思是，计算机确实可以通过某些方式犯错，这取决于你怎么看，除了我们说的……如果有时我的信用卡，我有几次遇到它检测到它认为是欺诈的情况，对吧？这是某台计算机在做，没有人在看我的信用卡历史，但某台计算机确定我当前的消费习惯
looks a lot like someone who stole my credit card and sometimes they're right one time they were buying those like rugs the indian rugs or something yeah that's like the number one thing if someone steals your credit card um they will buy indian rugs in fact somebody when they had the whole playstation fiasco um my credit card was one of the ones stolen and sure enough capital one calls me up and says did you buy you know four indian rugs that's like the first thing they asked me that's really odd well the one i've always heard before very expensive oh maybe is that teenagers typically go buy shoes and then buy gas for them and all their friends so if you fill up like it's like me and my spouse's car and then i went to the mall and bought something or whatever and like that'll trigger it oh wow um but no i specifically
看起来很像有人偷了我的信用卡，有时他们是对的。有一次他们买的是那种地毯，印度地毯之类的。是的，如果有人偷了你的信用卡，这是第一件事。他们会买印度地毯。事实上，当 PlayStation 发生那次惨败时，我的信用卡就是被盗的信用卡之一，果然 Capital One 打电话给我说，你买了四张印度地毯吗？那是他们问我的第一件事，真的很奇怪。好吧，我一直听说的是，非常昂贵。哦，也许是青少年通常去买鞋，然后给他们和所有的朋友买汽油。所以如果你加满油，就像我和我配偶的车，然后我去了商场买了什么东西之类的，那就会触发它。哦，哇。但不是，我特别
what it triggered triggered mine was i uh made a change in like my like i'd moved so i made a change in my address and then i ordered some computer parts online and apparently that also looks exactly like someone stole your credit card um which makes sense um but you know some computer made a mistake right like i didn't commit fraud um yeah right but did it really make a mistake no it probably did execute the rules it was told to but from my point of view it was a mistake i there was no fraud yeah yeah i mean that's the kind of thing like if it if you if you you know i'm assuming they built this really complicated fraud system that like projected all of your credit card purchases to some like
触发我的是，我搬家了，所以我更改了地址，然后我在网上订购了一些电脑零件，显然这看起来也完全像是有人偷了你的信用卡，这说得通。但你知道，某台计算机犯了一个错误，对吧？我没有进行欺诈。是的，没错。但它真的犯错了吗？不，它可能确实执行了被告知的规则，但从我的角度来看，这是一个错误。我没有欺诈。是的，我的意思是，如果他们建立了一个非常复杂的欺诈系统，将你所有的信用卡消费投射到某种……
really high dimensional latent space i mean at some point it's like i guess like making a mistake comes down to responsibility like i mean i guess at the end of the day you're always responsible for the for the computer you know but i mean like look at like these algorithmic trading computers where like they uh they do machine learning to like predict stock market prices and things like that i mean in, in that case, like you're saying, look, the computer is doing the trading, you know, hopefully it wins more than it loses. But at the end of the day, it's like, I don't know if that's really, yeah, the responsibility thing is kind of fuzzy.
非常高维的潜在空间。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我想犯错归结为责任。我的意思是，归根结底，你总是要为计算机负责，你知道。但看看这些算法交易计算机，它们进行机器学习来预测股市价格之类的。我的意思是，在这种情况下，就像你说的，看，计算机在进行交易，希望它赢多输少。但归根结底，我不知道这是否真的……是的，责任问题有点模糊。
So another mistake can be, it has sort of gotten to your stochastic processes thing, but that if you are running your processor at you know high temperature or close to uh you know its power limits you can you know have glitches which are problems or you know you always hear this classic thing but it is actually true that there are you know cosmic events you know radiation cosmic rays which cause uh you know logic levels to flip or invert temporarily and can inject noise at some level into the computer. And then the computer can think a zero is a one, right? And then all of a sudden that changes everything. Yeah. You know, very large
所以另一个错误可能是，这有点涉及到你的随机过程，但如果你在高温度下运行处理器，或者接近它的功率限制，你可能会遇到故障，也就是问题。或者你总是听到这个经典说法，但它确实是真的，那就是有宇宙事件，你知道，辐射、宇宙射线，会导致逻辑电平暂时翻转或反转，并可以在某种程度上向计算机注入噪声。然后计算机可能会认为 0 是 1，对吧？然后突然间，一切都变了。是的。你知道，非常大的
number is now a negative, large negative number because the first bit got flipped, right? Like that can happen. Yeah. Right. You know, statistically, it's, you know, basically not going to happen, but for someone, it will happen. Yeah, there's this interesting TED Talk. It was from the security chief of Twitter, and basically, she said, like, I don't remember exactly.
数字现在变成了负数，很大的负数，因为第一位被翻转了，对吧？这可能会发生。是的。没错。你知道，从统计学上讲，它基本上不会发生，但对某个人来说，它会发生。是的，有一个有趣的 TED 演讲。是来自 Twitter 的安全主管，基本上她说，我不记得确切的了。
I'm going to kind of butcher this, but she was saying something like, you know, if there's a one in a million chance that some crazy, you know, event would would happen like your stalker happens to find you on twitter randomly like if that's a one in a million chance then it happens 50 times an hour in twitter you know i mean like just and it's just kind of like i guess that's what i was trying to say yeah so the chance of your computer having a cosmic event change it in a meaningful way is you know one in a billion but the chance of a cosmic ray affecting someone change it in a meaningful way is you know one in a billion but the chance
我可能会说得乱七八糟，但她说的是，如果有一百万分之一的机会发生某种疯狂的事件，比如你的跟踪者随机在 Twitter 上找到你，如果那是一百万分之一的机会，那么在 Twitter 上每小时就会发生 50 次。你知道我的意思吗？这只是……我想这就是我想说的。是的，所以你的计算机因为宇宙事件而以有意义的方式改变的机会是十亿分之一，但宇宙射线以有意义的方式影响某人的机会是十亿分之一，但
of a cosmic ray affecting someone's computer in a meaningful way is you know very high in a given day yeah right right so um but yeah so yeah okay i don't know does it make any relevant uh difference today probably not but it is an interesting question. Yeah, yeah, totally. So for like kind of, do you want to do news first or do you want to cover this? Let's cover this. Okay, cool. So yeah, I don't know how I got on this, but somehow I, oh yeah. So I feel very compelled to like, I'm working with a lot of people who are just fresh out of college. And so it's kind of cool.
宇宙射线以有意义的方式影响某人的计算机的机会在某一天是非常高的。是的，没错。所以……好吧，我不知道这在今天有什么相关的影响吗？可能没有，但这是一个有趣的问题。是的，完全同意。那么，你想先讲新闻还是想讨论这个？我们讨论这个吧。好的，酷。所以，我不知道我是怎么扯到这上面的，但不知何故我……哦，对了。所以我感到非常有必要，我正在和很多刚从大学毕业的人一起工作。所以这很酷。
Like, it feels like you're looking at yourself, like, but younger or just, like, less experienced. Because, like, they did all, they're doing all the same things I did. And it's like I, you know know can't obviously fault them for it but it's like I think it's like in hindsight it's it's clear like there's like lessons that neither one of us like like no one myself nor any of these other people have learned the easy way and we're all having to learn it the hard way um actually well hopefully I can make it so that they don't have to learn it the hard way but I wanted to take a little bit of time to talk about like rookie software engineer mistakes and so the tldr of this inch of this intro is that you're getting old
感觉就像你在看你自己，但更年轻，或者只是经验不足。因为他们做的所有事情和我做的一样。我显然不能因此责怪他们，但我觉得事后看来，很清楚，有些教训无论是我们俩中的任何一个，还是我自己，或者这些其他人，都没有通过简单的方式学到，我们都必须通过困难的方式来学习。其实，希望我能让他们不必通过困难的方式来学习。但我还是想花点时间谈谈新手软件工程师的错误。所以这段介绍的总结就是你老了。
i mean wise i mean wise wise you're getting wise oh there was a quora question it said uh what the old software engineers in silicon valley do or like what happens to old software engineers and the number one answer was this guy he said they become well-paid software engineers i don't know if that's true or not but uh um but it was kind of interesting it made me think that like there really aren't that many old software engineers like you don't see a lot of like 50 60 year old software engineers and there's you don't see a lot of, like, 50-, 60-year-old software engineers. And there's probably a bunch of reasons for that. Wait, I...
我的意思是智慧，我的意思是智慧，你变得睿智了。哦，有一个 Quora 问题，它说硅谷的老软件工程师做什么，或者老软件工程师会发生什么，排名第一的回答是这个家伙，他说他们变成了高薪的软件工程师。我不知道这是不是真的，但它很有趣，让我觉得确实没有那么多老软件工程师。你不会看到很多 50、60 岁的软件工程师。而且你不会看到很多 50、60 岁的软件工程师。这可能有很多原因。等等，我……
Okay. Anyways, I digress. Yeah. But so that's why we're thinking we're old, right? Anyways, so a couple of rookie software engineer mistakes. One of them, and this is a big one is like making assumptions and it's either because you want to you know kind of save time or save processing or you don't want to change the schema or something like that so like uh you know i purposely didn't like no one
好吧。总之，我离题了。是的。但这就是为什么我们觉得我们老了，对吧？总之，几个新手软件工程师的错误。其中之一，这是一个大错误，就是做出假设。这要么是因为你想节省时间或节省处理能力，要么是因为你不想更改模式之类的。所以，你知道，我故意没有……没有人
on my team actually said any of these or anything like that but uh but this is like a like a fictitious example is you know you have some document system and you store the timestamp for all the documents and then all of a sudden you need to know whether you know document was created by an admin or not and rather than having some boolean which says you know created by admin you say oh I know what I'll do you know if the timestamp is negative i'll just flip the sign of the timestamp um if it's negative then it's an admin um and so like things like that work but the problem is you're kind of setting up a landmine for your future self you know what i mean because you're you're now like adding this cognitive overhead where you have to remember this sort of association that you only
在我的团队中真正说过这些话之类的，但这只是一个虚构的例子。你有一个文档系统，你存储了所有文档的时间戳，然后突然你需要知道文档是否由管理员创建。与其使用一个布尔值来表示“由管理员创建”，你说：“哦，我知道该怎么做了，如果时间戳是负数，我就翻转时间戳的符号，如果它是负数，那就是管理员。”所以像这样的事情确实有效，但问题是你正在为未来的自己埋下地雷。你知道我的意思吗？因为你现在增加了这种认知负担，你必须记住这种关联，而你只是因为当时方便才编造出来的。
made up because it was kind of convenient you know given the circumstances um and so you see just a ton of this kind of stuff where you know people will uh people will just kind of it's not really a shortcut because like often it's just that much time. You're overloading. Yeah, I do see this a lot. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Optimization, yeah, you're overloading a field or a value to mean multiple things, and it just makes it convoluted instead of breaking out to explicit fields. Yeah, exactly.
所以你会看到大量这种事情，人们只是……这并不是真正的捷径，因为通常这需要同样多的时间。你在重载。是的，我确实经常看到这种情况。是的，没错，完全正确。优化，是的，你在重载一个字段或值来表示多种含义，这只会让它变得复杂，而不是拆分成明确的字段。是的，完全正确。
I mean, another case of this, it's like a little bit of a different vein, but it's where someone starts off with like current measurements, like double current measurement, and then they need the previous measurement. So they're like double previous measurement, double current measurement. And you're like, okay. But then they realize they need the last 10 measurements. And they're like previous, previous measurement. You know what I mean? And it's just like, it just grows organically. And the previous measurement you know what i mean and it's just like it just grows organically and the next thing you know you like have this ridiculous thing that could just be an array right or the other pet peeve of mine is uh even in you know i guess this is more common maybe in dynamically typed languages like python but uh and i even see people do this and see but
我的意思是，这种情况的另一个例子，虽然有点不同，但有人从当前的测量值开始，比如双精度当前测量值，然后他们需要之前的测量值。所以他们写了“双精度之前测量值，双精度当前测量值”。你会说，好吧。但后来他们意识到他们需要最后 10 个测量值。他们就写了“之前，之前测量值”。你知道我的意思吗？它只是有机地增长。而之前的测量值……你知道我的意思吗？它只是有机地增长，接下来你知道，你就有了一个荒谬的东西，而它本可以只是一个数组，对吧？或者我的另一个心头大患是……即使在……我想这在动态类型语言（如 Python）中可能更常见，但我甚至看到人们在 C 中也这样做。
like you'll have some you know unsigned 8-bit integer that is getting some value uh from a function then later they also use it to get a value from a different function like later in that function you know but now these are two different things but they just reuse the same variable and it's like here the variable meant this now down here the variable means this like why don't you just create a new like the compiler will you know optimize this away there's no reason for you to reuse the same variable name twice like in a loop like if you're looping and the loops aren't related like fine like i'm okay like having the variable i counter or whatever be used but like syntactically like they don't it's just like here's one value then here's a value from a completely unrelated function
你会有一个无符号 8 位整数，从一个函数获取某个值，然后稍后在同一个函数中，他们又用它从另一个函数获取值。但现在这是两件不同的事情，但他们只是重用了同一个变量。就像这里变量意味着这个，现在下面变量意味着那个。为什么你不直接创建一个新的？编译器会优化掉它，你没有理由在循环中重用同一个变量名两次。比如如果你在循环，而循环不相关，那没关系，我没意见，使用变量 i 计数器之类的。但从语法上讲，它只是……这里是一个值，然后这里是一个来自完全不相关函数的值，
that also just happens to be of the same size and i no longer needed the other one so i'll just reuse the name it's like oh just create a new name yeah yeah that stuff is brutal um another one that i see a lot is uh people who don't put like asserts or exceptions or like to some extent tests in their code i mean everyone always complains about no tests but even just like asserts and exceptions you know i mean it doesn't take much time to as you're going through say okay you know i expect this list to have three things in it so if it doesn't have three things then blow up you know um like code a lot of the code i write like you know a few days later will blow up or a week later will blow up.
它恰好也是相同的大小，而且我不再需要原来的那个了，所以我只是重用这个名字。就像，哦，直接创建一个新名字吧。是的，那种东西很残酷。另一个我经常看到的是，人们不在代码中放置断言、异常或某种程度上的测试。我的意思是，每个人总是抱怨没有测试，但即使只是断言和异常，你知道，在编写过程中花点时间说：“好的，我期望这个列表里有三个东西，所以如果它没有三个东西，就报错。”你知道，我写的很多代码，几天后就会报错，或者一周后就会报错。
And usually it's because some other part of the system violated one of the assumptions that I wrote. Or even if it blows up a year later, it's even better. Because instead of just some really weird runtime condition that maybe you don't even notice for a long time, it's like a year later, all of a sudden it's like, boom, exception. I expected the list to be three, now it's four. And usually, you know, the exception will fire immediately after someone makes the change that causes the problem, right?
通常是因为系统的其他部分违反了我写下的假设之一。或者即使它一年后才报错，那更好。因为与其出现一些你可能很长时间都没注意到的奇怪运行时状况，不如一年后突然出现一个异常：“我期望列表是三个，现在是四个。”通常，异常会在有人做出导致问题的更改后立即触发，对吧？
So you don't have these like really weird latent um issues that you have to like go back and play detective to figure out you know as you work in really really large systems this is where like continuous integration and unit tests become absolutely crucial so you you even if you test your code, if you've changed something that other people were assuming about your code, and they don't also have tests, or there isn't some system doing integration testing, then it can go undiscovered for a while. Yep. Yeah, totally. That's hard, right? Somebody in the chat said they don't like it when uh negative one is used to represent a failure state that is another good thing like you see that where it's like the function you
所以你不会有那些需要你回去当侦探才能弄清楚的奇怪潜在问题。当你处理非常大的系统时，这就是持续集成和单元测试变得绝对关键的地方。所以即使你测试了你的代码，如果你更改了其他人对你的代码所做的假设，而他们也没有测试，或者没有系统在做集成测试，那么它可能会在一段时间内不被发现。是的。完全同意。这很难，对吧？聊天室里有人说他们不喜欢用负 1 来表示失败状态，这也是一个好点。你看到那种情况，函数
know returns an int but yet you know they want they really want to return an int and you know something else for the status but instead of returning like a pair they return an int and they're like okay this is going to be positive except it's negative one if this is negative two if like cows are flying and it's negative three if it's a if it's a monday and you're just like ah i can't deal yeah well i'm similarly yes i did have this problem with a new person on on a team i had to help try to convince them which i don't know how successful i was but they had where it uh they would call some computation function it would return a result then you needed to call another function that said whether the value returned was currently valid or not so like you know some state
返回一个 int，但他们真的想返回一个 int，以及其他状态信息，但他们没有返回一个对（pair），而是返回一个 int，他们说：“好的，这应该是正数，除非它是负 1，如果这是负 2，如果牛在飞，如果它是负 3，如果今天是星期一。”你只会觉得，啊，我受不了了。好吧，我也有类似的情况。是的，我团队里的一个新人确实有这个问题，我不得不帮他们说服，我不知道我有多成功，但他们有这种情况，他们会调用某个计算函数，它返回一个结果，然后你需要调用另一个函数来判断返回的值当前是否有效。所以，你知道，某种状态
is being tracked and you need to call first and say hey is this other function going to be valid if i call it or if i've called it is it currently valid and i was like why don't you just return boolean of whether it's valid and then like you know in this case it was uh c so you know and then pass a pointer in and then you'll know like if it's valid the value in the pointer is now you know the pointer the yeah right is now set to and they And they're like, I don't know. Like, why can't you just call this other function? I'm like, well, because then if someone doesn't call that function, then, like, they have no idea if, like,
正在被跟踪，你需要先调用并说：“嘿，如果我调用这个其他函数，它会有效吗？或者如果我已经调用了它，它当前有效吗？”我说：“为什么你不直接返回一个布尔值来表示它是否有效？然后，在这种情况下，它是 C，所以你知道，然后传入一个指针，然后你就会知道，如果它有效，指针中的值现在就是……指针……是的，没错……现在被设置了。”他们说：“我不知道。为什么你不能直接调用这个其他函数？”我说：“好吧，因为如果有人不调用那个函数，那么他们就不知道你是否会给他们垃圾。”
you're just going to give them garbage. Yeah, I mean, this is why you're forcing them to study that. And they're like, well, they could ignore the fact that you're returning a Boolean. I'm like, yeah, but at least it's, like, more obvious to someone reviewing the code that, hey, why is this returning a Boolean and why are you ignoring it? Yeah, right, right. I mean, in some languages, you can't ignore return values, like not without the compiler getting mad at you and stuff. Which is a good thing.
是的，我的意思是，这就是为什么你强迫他们去研究那个。他们说：“好吧，他们可以忽略你返回布尔值的事实。”我说：“是的，但至少对于审查代码的人来说，这更明显，嘿，为什么这个返回布尔值，而你却忽略了它？”是的，没错。我的意思是，在某些语言中，你不能忽略返回值，除非编译器对你发火之类的。这是一件好事。
Yeah, that's right. So, okay. Cool, man. Do you do exceptions in C? i don't think yeah so uh can't do anything there but i do have assertions okay that's good and typically the way i've always i see it is that you have assertions disabled when you're in release but in debug you have them yeah that makes sense um and so that that always leads to this debate should you have non-disable assertion so then you end up with debug only assertions and then regular assertions
是的，那没错。所以，好的。酷。伙计，你在 C 中使用异常吗？我不认为……是的，所以……那里什么也做不了，但我有断言。好的，那很好。通常我看到的方式是，你在发布版本中禁用断言，但在调试版本中启用它们。是的，这说得通。所以这总是导致这个争论：你应该有不可禁用的断言吗？所以你最终会有仅调试断言和常规断言。
and what is semantics around it but it gets really yeah then it depends sort of on you know do you want is your goal that the system survives anything? Or is your goal that you fail loudly? Can you even theoretically recover from this? Yeah, right. So, yeah, well. The last one, reinventing the wheel. There's a ton of good source code out there. A lot of it is very liberally licensed
以及它周围的语义是什么，但这确实……是的，然后这取决于你的目标是系统在任何情况下都能存活？还是你的目标是响亮地失败？你理论上能从中恢复吗？是的，没错。所以，好吧。最后一个，重新发明轮子。外面有很多好的源代码。其中很多是自由许可的。
you don't need to Go and like create your own hash table and things like that. There's a lot of it for you So yeah, I think this is a big one actually and I think that like actually, you know connecting up libraries is really hard I mean, especially in a lower level language like C You're wiring together libraries, you know, they might have different structs and you have to maybe do some fancy casting or you have to, you know, translate back and forth. And, you know, doing that stuff efficiently is really hard. Like it's cerebral. And, you know, coding something from scratch is much more like mechanical in a sense.'s easier. when you code from scratch,
你不需要去创建你自己的哈希表之类的东西。有很多现成的。所以是的，我认为这是一个大问题。而且我认为，实际上，连接库真的很难。我的意思是，特别是在像 C 这样的低级语言中，你把库连接在一起，它们可能有不同的结构体，你可能必须做一些花哨的转换，或者你必须来回翻译。而且，高效地做这些事情真的很难。这很费脑子。而且，从零开始编写代码在某种意义上更机械，更容易。当你从零开始编写代码时，
you're going to introduce all these errors that you're going to have to debug. You're not going to write perfect code. And you're not going to write code that's as well tested as an open source library that's ubiquitous. So, yeah, so this is just another one that
你会引入所有必须调试的错误。你不会写出完美的代码。而且你不会写出像无处不在的开源库那样经过充分测试的代码。所以，是的，这只是另一个我倾向于经常看到的错误。
I kind of tend to see a lot of so depending on your company using open source libraries may or may not get you into endless waiting with the lawyers uh yeah so it depends on the license like yes are you a lawyer am i a lawyer no yeah okay then If you work at any large company, regardless of that you know this license is safe to use, they'll first want it to be reviewed by a lawyer. Yeah, that's true. There are lawyer cats.
所以根据你的公司，使用开源库可能会也可能不会让你陷入与律师无休止的等待中。是的，这取决于许可证。你是律师吗？我是律师吗？不。好的，那么如果你在任何大公司工作，不管你知不知道这个许可证是否可以安全使用，他们首先会希望由律师审查。是的，那是真的。有律师猫。
That just... Yeah, I guess it depends on... Usually the lawyer cats are pretty responsive. We had an issue where they didn't approve emax 24 but people were just using it nobody really thought anything of it and finally
那只是……是的，我想这取决于……通常律师猫反应很快。我们曾经有一个问题，他们没有批准 Emacs 24，但人们只是在使用它，没人真正想什么，最后
somebody was like oh we should probably ask the lawyer cats and they sent an email and it was approved like within a couple hours yeah oh i'm not saying all lawyers are bad i just mean typically depending on your you know company they may or may you as programmers, we sometimes say, oh, I know this license is, you know, friendly or, you know, fine to use, or this is in the public domain. I'll just go ahead and use it. But, you know, there's also someone needs to be tracking everything you're using because typically you're also supposed to at least give credit or site. Oh, yeah. You're using something, right? So you have to make sure you have procedures in place so that you are keeping track of everything you're using yeah definitely actually
有人说：“哦，我们可能应该问问律师猫。”他们发了一封电子邮件，几个小时内就批准了。是的，哦，我不是说所有律师都坏，我只是说通常根据你的公司，你作为程序员，有时会说：“哦，我知道这个许可证是友好的，或者可以安全使用，或者这是公共领域的。我就直接用吧。”但你知道，也需要有人跟踪你正在使用的所有东西，因为通常你还应该至少给予信用或引用。哦，是的。你在使用某样东西，对吧？所以你必须确保有程序到位，以便跟踪你正在使用的所有东西。是的，绝对。其实
that's interesting that i wonder if there's like a git hook for that you know where it somehow like git can become aware of your what open source libraries you're using i don't know i don't know where i'm going with that time for the news news so i'm gonna go first okay so i got the first article and uh i'm not super uh good with markov chains so i don't know how good this description of markov chains in this article is but i thought it was a really interesting... This isn't how I traditionally see Markov chains, but it was an interesting approach that... The link will be in the show notes. But this person had read a Reddit posting
这很有趣，我想知道是否有 git hook 可以做到这一点，你知道，它以某种方式让 git 意识到你正在使用什么开源库。我不知道，我不知道我要说什么。新闻时间到了。新闻。所以我先来。好的，我拿到了第一篇文章。我对马尔可夫链不是很精通，所以我不知道这篇文章对马尔可夫链的描述有多好，但我认为这是一个非常有趣的……这不是我传统上看到马尔可夫链的方式，但这是一个有趣的方法……链接会在节目说明中。但这个人读了一篇 Reddit 帖子，
of a challenge, of a programming challenge, how do you simulate this collection of particles undergoing radioactive decay, where you get, here's the starting number of particles in various states, and here's the probability that a particle decays from one state to another state the second state to a third state so on and so forth and so they were talking about that you know if you have a million particles one way to do it is you know essentially pick a random number for each of the particles and then determine based on the the specified if that particular particle, you know, transition state or not.
关于一个编程挑战，如何模拟这种经历放射性衰变的粒子集合，你得到：这是各种状态下的起始粒子数量，这是粒子从一种状态衰变到另一种状态、第二种状态到第三种状态等等的概率。所以他们在谈论，如果你有一百万个粒子，一种方法是本质上为每个粒子选择一个随机数，然后根据指定的概率确定该特定粒子是否转换状态。
And how that this, you know, obviously is very costly and slow. And then instead how that, you know, what they were saying was using Markov chains, but what amounts to creating a probability matrices and what they were calling a transfer function that you can essentially do a matrix multiplication and essentially do the same thing almost exactly. So you're not simulating each particle,
以及这显然是非常昂贵和缓慢的。然后相反，他们说的是使用马尔可夫链，但相当于创建概率矩阵和他们所说的传递函数，你可以本质上进行矩阵乘法，几乎完全做同样的事情。所以你不是在模拟每个粒子，
but you're simulating kind of all of them simultaneously, you know, undergoing this. And then what populations will you end up with at the end? It was a good article. So for really large numbers. You're solving like the recurrence, right? That's right's right yeah you're solving like several steps in one yeah cool and so wouldn't i i it didn't exactly i know i'm trying to remember but i you know i don't think this would work for a really small number like if you had you know three particles right like
而是在同时模拟它们所有，经历这个过程。然后你最终会得到什么人口？这是一篇好文章。所以对于非常大的数字。你是在求解递归，对吧？没错。是的，你在一步中求解几个步骤。酷。所以，我不知道……我试图记住，但我认为这对于非常小的数字不起作用，比如如果你有三个粒子，对吧？
it's random so maybe it'll work but you're gonna have some weird stuff going on but when you get into large numbers right like it it really all does it all just becomes statistical yeah yeah so that was one of those things that like kind of blew my mind i mean a while back it's like this idea where uh that that sort of i'm trying to see if i can grok this so it's like oh yeah it's like you know if you're if you have a 50 chance of something happening and and uh everyone in america has that chance then that means half the people in america have it and half don't so this idea of going from like chance to, you know, sample like populations, it's sort of like, yeah, like if you, if, if, uh, 10% of the people have a tattoo, there's like 30 million people with tattoos or something like that. Like that whole going from like percentages to like, it's like, oh yeah. You know, like at some point when the sample size is large enough percentages become fractions yeah it's your it's not exam not a statistician but it's like your confidence interval right so like if 10 have tattoos and you have five people like how many
它是随机的，所以也许它会起作用，但你会遇到一些奇怪的事情，但当你进入大数字时，它真的就变成了统计学。是的，所以这是那种让我大开眼界的事情之一。我的意思是，很久以前，这就像是一个想法，如果你有 50% 的机会发生某事，而美国的每个人都有这个机会，那就意味着美国一半的人有，一半没有。所以这种从机会到样本人口的想法，就像，如果 10% 的人有纹身，就有 3000 万人有纹身之类的。那种从百分比到……就像，哦，是的。你知道，在某种程度上，当样本量足够大时，百分比就变成了分数。是的，你不是统计学家，但就像你的置信区间，对吧？所以如果 10% 有纹身，你有五个人，有多少
people have tattoos it's like well if all five did that doesn't really prove anything Like it doesn't say for certain that your 10% was wrong. It just like could be that you got really a very rare, a low probability event happened. Right. But, you know, if you're like you said, 100 million people and you say 10% have tattoos, you're going to be plus or minus a few like, you know, in the 99% confidence interval, your standard, like the amount of variance you expect to see is really low. That's right. Yeah. Yeah. So this is taking that same approach. But it was an interesting thing to remind us that when you start to deal with very large numbers of something that you maybe need to step away from actually literally simulating it.
人有纹身？如果所有五个人都有，那并不能证明什么。它并不能确定地说你的 10% 是错的。它只是可能发生了非常罕见的、低概率的事件。没错。但是，如果你像你说的，1 亿人，你说 10% 有纹身，你会在 99% 的置信区间内，正负几个，你期望看到的方差量真的很低。没错。是的。所以这是采取同样的方法。但这提醒我们，当你开始处理非常大数量的某物时，你可能需要远离字面上的模拟。
Yeah, actually, I was given an interview interview question which is exactly this problem oh really yeah the interview question was i'm totally gonna butcher this but it was something to the effect of it was something about like disk seeking so uh you know it's like you want to write data in a way where when you read the data you could read it consecutively. But you don't know for sure how you're going to read the data. But anyway, it boiled down to
是的，其实我被问过一个面试问题，正是这个问题。哦，真的吗？面试问题是，我完全会搞砸，但大概意思是关于磁盘寻道。所以，你知道，你想以一种方式写入数据，当你读取数据时，你可以连续读取它。但你不知道你将如何读取数据。但无论如何，它归结为
treating the problem of going from one item of data you're reading to the next, treating it as a Markov chain. and it was it ended up being exactly this so uh so yeah so read this article you could you could answer an interview question uh so mine is uh my article is axis destroy your friends with math functions um it looks pretty cool um i saw the video I tried to play it but they don't have
将从一个数据项读取到下一个数据项的问题视为马尔可夫链。结果完全是这样。所以，是的，读读这篇文章，你可以回答一个面试问题。所以我的文章是《用数学函数摧毁你的朋友》，看起来很酷。我看了视频，我试着玩，但他们没有
a single player so I haven't actually played it yet but I think the idea is you know there's some islands that are you can think of them as like walls you can't hit and then there's a tank or some enemy and you have to draw some function that carves its way around these walls and hits the person and it's like that game uh scorched earth oh yeah yeah yeah where like you had the angle and the velocity of a you know basically you defined a ray and based on that ray you shot a projectile that you know arced with gravity and had to hit somebody so it's that kind of idea, but they really took it to the next level.
单人模式，所以我还没玩过，但我认为这个想法是，有一些岛屿，你可以把它们看作墙，你不能撞到，然后有一个坦克或某个敌人，你必须画一个函数，绕过这些墙并击中那个人。就像那个游戏《焦土》（Scorched Earth）。哦，是的，在那里你有角度和速度，基本上你定义了一条射线，基于那条射线，你发射了一个受重力影响的弹丸，必须击中某人。所以是那种想法，但他们真的把它提升到了一个新的水平。
You come up with some crazy sine wave that dodges a wall and hits somebody. I thought it was pretty cool. Check it out. If you want to destroy us, feel free to invite us. I don't actually know...
你想出一个疯狂的正弦波，躲过一堵墙并击中某人。我觉得这很酷。去看看吧。如果你想摧毁我们，欢迎邀请我们。我其实不知道……
I think the way the multiplayer works is you have to send someone a link or something. But yeah, try it out. Yeah, let us know what you think. Next article is why Python is slow. And for the sake of time, I won't go into all of the reasons enumerated in this article, but it's a very fascinating under the hood look
我想多人游戏的工作方式是你必须给某人发送一个链接之类的。但试一试吧。是的，让我们知道你的想法。下一篇文章是《为什么 Python 很慢》。为了节省时间，我不会列举这篇文章中提到的所有原因，但这是一个非常迷人的底层观察。
at the mechanics of Python. So we talk about, oh, Python is, you know, dynamically typed and interpreted. But, you know, like what is the actual thing going under the hood that causes it to be that much slower than, you know, C++ or whatever? And this guy did a really good job of breaking it down kind of piece by piece. And it gives a lot of insight, you know, that you would never think about kind of ordinarily you might at a high level say oh python you know uses an object to represent an integer but how exactly um and this article goes into that so check it out yeah it's awesome um yeah so this next one is uh the day i lost a ton of money and it's a you're censoring yourself i'm censoring yeah it's it's a ton of money um an s ton of money and uh and that's not like an s expression different kind
关于 Python 的机制。我们常说，哦，Python 是动态类型且解释执行的。但你有没有想过，到底是什么底层原因导致它比 C++ 之类的语言慢那么多？这篇文章把这个问题拆解得非常透彻。它提供了很多你平时根本不会去想的见解，比如你可能在宏观上说 Python 用对象来表示整数，但具体是怎么实现的呢？这篇文章深入探讨了这一点，去看看吧，真的很棒。嗯，下一个话题是“我损失巨额资金的那一天”，你这是在自我审查吗？我在审查，是的，那是一大笔钱，真的是一大笔钱，而且这可不是什么 S 表达式，是另一种
of s oh but basically uh uh it's from this guy who's like a day trader and she kind of blew my mind um like just like how this whole thing works and and how these people like you know try like analyze the market or don't in this case and and just lose a ton of other people's money i mean it's kind of sad but the whole thing is kind of interesting um it's has some funny pictures and stuff like that so uh i haven't read this yet but it was it is interesting i like i i was just skimming i was like what is going on here yeah so basically this guy you know it's all about his it's like your stereotypical you know rise to power and then and then you know eminent destruction so uh yes so time for on to book of the show show show my book of the show is emacs quick
S，哦，基本上，这是一个日内交易员的故事，它真的让我大开眼界。比如，整个系统是如何运作的，这些人是如何尝试分析市场的（或者像这个案例中那样根本不分析），然后赔光了别人的钱。这虽然有点可悲，但整个过程很有趣，里面还有一些搞笑的图片之类的。我还没读完，但它确实很有意思，我刚才扫了一眼，心想这到底是怎么回事。基本上，这个人的故事就是典型的“崛起然后走向毁灭”。好了，现在是节目推荐书环节，我的推荐是 Emacs 快速
reference card but it's not only emacs um In general, reference cards are pretty awesome. I have had the Emacs reference card taped to my computer monitor for, I don't know, way too long. I have one of these for GDB. Oh, do you really? Yes. Are there really that many commands in GDB? Yes. Have you used gdb before i the only thing i've done with gdb is halt the program
参考卡，但不仅仅是 Emacs。总的来说，参考卡非常棒。我不知道把 Emacs 参考卡贴在电脑显示器上有多久了，时间长到离谱。我甚至还有一张 GDB 的参考卡。哦，真的吗？是的。GDB 里真的有那么多命令吗？是的。你以前用过 GDB 吗？我用 GDB 唯一做过的事就是暂停程序，
when there's a c++ exception so i know like two commands in gdb oh there are yes many many commands in gdb okay so uh yeah in general there's a reference card for almost everything like if if you're doing j, there's a Java reference card. I'm curious what a Java reference card has on it. Good question. Some of these things which are more muscle memory type things, it's really good to have a reference card.
当出现 C++ 异常时，所以我只知道 GDB 里的两个命令。哦，是的，GDB 里确实有非常非常多的命令。好吧，总的来说，几乎所有东西都有参考卡。比如如果你在用 Java，就有 Java 参考卡。我很好奇 Java 参考卡上都有什么。好问题。对于一些更依赖肌肉记忆的东西，有一张参考卡真的很有用。
Sometimes you're right there on the spot and you're like, oh, I want to move this line up two lines. I don't want to cut it and paste it. and you're like oh i want to you know move this line up two lines but like i don't want to like cut it and paste it or you know like if you're feeling kind of adventurous you can just look at the quick reference card and it might have something you can like slowly add it to your repository so for things like emacs vim you know eclipse things which have keyboard shortcuts also if like if you're learning a brand new language
有时候你就在现场，心想，哦，我想把这一行向上移动两行。我不想剪切再粘贴。你心想，哦，我想把这一行向上移动两行，但我不想剪切再粘贴。或者，如果你感觉有点冒险，你可以看看快速参考卡，它可能有一些东西，你可以慢慢把它添加到你的代码库中。所以对于像 Emacs、Vim、Eclipse 这种有键盘快捷键的工具，或者如果你正在学习一门全新的语言，
um rather than just like hitting google every time it's like how do i do a for loop how do i add you know it's like have a quick reference card and it will help you through like i had this when i was learning um swift i just someone had already made a swift quick reference card or maybe even apple had made it i don't know i have to double check but i i had this quick reference card and it reminded me of you know the obvious things until i got familiar yeah so what's the java quick reference card say well first of all it's crazy like description of the collections like oh god list is a part of a collection an abstract set is you've related to a set which is part of a. Like it has this like giant map on one part. And I was like all the keywords.
与其每次都去谷歌搜索“怎么写 for 循环”或者“怎么添加……”，不如准备一张快速参考卡，它会帮你度过难关。我学习 Swift 的时候就是这样，有人已经做好了 Swift 快速参考卡，或者可能是苹果官方做的，我不知道，我得核实一下。但我有这张快速参考卡，它提醒了我那些显而易见的事情，直到我熟悉为止。那么 Java 快速参考卡上写了什么？首先，它很疯狂，比如对集合的描述，天哪，List 是集合的一部分，抽象 Set 与 Set 相关，而 Set 是……的一部分。它在某一部分有一个巨大的映射图。我当时想，这上面全是关键字。
So a lot of it is kind of, I don't know, maybe I consider too low level. Like here's the built-in types. Here's declaration modifiers. Yeah. I think I'd like to just get the one from like, here's a declaration modifier,
所以很多内容，我不知道，也许我觉得太底层了。比如这里是内置类型，这里是声明修饰符。是的，我想我只想看那种，比如，这是一个声明修饰符，
which I didn't know existed in Java strict FP. And it says strictly apply. I Tripoli seven, five, four to a class or method but i don't know like i can vaguely guess at what that means because i understand the words that are written here but i don't like i'd have to go look this up anyways are you looking at the one from nyu.edu oh i just typed in java quick reference card i typed in just java reference card i'm looking at one from oh ac.uk university of glasgow glasgow okay i'm putting in one now oh this is uh this is intense so i'm not sure that's useful the one from nyu if you search for quick reference card
我以前不知道 Java 里有 strictfp。它说将 IEEE 754 标准严格应用于类或方法。但我不知道，我只能模糊地猜出它的意思，因为我理解上面写的词，但我还是得去查一下。你是在看 nyu.edu 的那张吗？哦，我只是输入了“Java 快速参考卡”，我输入的是“Java 参考卡”，我正在看一张来自 ac.uk 格拉斯哥大学的。好的，我正在输入另一张。哦，这个太硬核了，我不确定它是否有用。如果你搜索“快速参考卡”，nyu 的那张
java quick reference card that one actually looks pretty good it's a second link because the first one's an android app um okay but uh but yeah again like like this is really i mean this is for two things either muscle memory kind of things like like emacs you know your editor where there's like a huge deep learning curve and you just don't want to bite it all at once because a lot of it is situational right it's good for those things and it's good for you know java i'm a java programmer it's day one and uh you know i don't know how to do anything yet um so you know if you're picking up a new language uh you know duct tape the quick reference card to your head. Don't duct tape. Oh, okay. We're just moving on. Duct tape it to your monitor, and it helps a lot. My book of the show, again, not being useful, but being entertaining,
Java 快速参考卡看起来确实不错，它是第二个链接，因为第一个是个安卓应用。好吧，但话说回来，这真的很有用，它适用于两件事：要么是肌肉记忆类的东西，比如 Emacs 这种编辑器，学习曲线非常陡峭，你不想一次性全部吞下，因为很多东西是情境化的；要么是像 Java 这种，我是 Java 程序员，今天是第一天，我什么都不知道。所以，如果你正在学习一门新语言，把快速参考卡贴在你的头上。别贴在头上。哦，好吧，我们继续。把它贴在显示器上，这很有帮助。我的节目推荐书，同样，不是为了实用，而是为了娱乐，
is The Moat in God's Eye. This is a book co-written by Larry Niven and Jerry Purnell. It was written in 1974. So I really am digging these, these like 1970s and 80s books because this one actually doesn't show its age as much as some of the other ones I read. But I didn't realize it was written in 1974 when I was starting to read it. I was actually listening to this one on audio. But when I was starting to read it it i didn't actually realize it was written that long ago and there were some weird mentions of like personal computers and like like having
是《上帝之眼中的微尘》（The Mote in God's Eye）。这是拉里·尼文（Larry Niven）和杰里·普内尔（Jerry Pournelle）合著的书，写于 1974 年。我真的很喜欢这些 70 和 80 年代的书，因为这一本并没有像我读过的其他一些书那样显得过时。但我开始读的时候并没有意识到它是 1974 年写的。我其实是在听这本书的音频版。但当我开始读的时候，我并没有意识到它写于那么久以前，书里有一些奇怪的提及，比如个人电脑，还有像
audible like connect almost like an audible modem was being described and i'm like that's kind of weird and later i looked at but but i managed to read the whole story and not realize that it was written in 1974 and i looked it up oh now that i know it's written in 1974. And I looked it up, and I'm like, oh, now that I know it was written in 1974, I understand these weird, like, the computers they did have were very limited, and they had weird nuances to them. Yeah, right. And so now I've ruined it if you decide to read it. But it is a really good book.
听起来几乎像是在描述一个声学调制解调器，我心想这有点奇怪。后来我查了一下，但我设法读完了整个故事，并没有意识到它是 1974 年写的。我查了一下，哦，现在我知道它是 1974 年写的了。我查了一下，心想，哦，现在我知道它是 1974 年写的了，我理解了这些奇怪的地方，比如他们拥有的电脑非常有限，而且有一些奇怪的细微差别。是的，没错。所以如果你决定读它，现在我把它剧透了。但它确实是一本好书。
In the future, we'll have microwaves. Well, so it's like you know oh the magnetic memory storage was one megabyte in size it's like that's so good no that's not exactly but you know something sort of like that yeah right no it's hilarious and but but they managed to do a really good job actually of avoiding specific technologies which has got to be hard to do yeah yeah definitely and so but anyways it's a it's a story about i don't like saying too much because i don't want to ruin anything but it's a space sci-fi adventure so cool man check it out i really enjoyed it and apparently i just found out when i was getting the link for the show notes that uh there's now there's actually a sequel that was
在未来，我们将会有微波炉。所以就像，哦，磁存储器只有 1 兆字节大小，这太棒了，不，那不完全是，但类似的东西。是的，没错，这太搞笑了。但他们确实做得很好，避免了具体的科技细节，这一定很难做到。是的，绝对是。总之，这是一个故事，我不想说太多，因为我不想剧透任何东西，但这是一部太空科幻冒险小说。太酷了，去看看吧，我真的很喜欢。而且我刚刚在找节目笔记链接时发现，现在其实有一部续集，是
written in like the 90s so now i like want to read the sequel oh is it by the same person well it's two people and jerry pernell they're both science fiction authors and they got together to write this book and the sequel wow so they got together 20 years later to write the sequel so these people are like like like very prolific writer. So if you've ever heard of ring world, uh, I think that was also, hang on,
在 90 年代写的，所以我现在想读续集。哦，是同一个人写的吗？嗯，是两个人，杰里·普内尔，他们都是科幻作家，他们聚在一起写了这本书和续集。哇，所以他们 20 年后又聚在一起写了续集，这些人真是多产的作家。如果你听说过《环形世界》（Ringworld），我想那也是，等等，
I'm going to, which one is it? But that's Larry Niven as well in the seventies wrote this ring world book. Oh, okay. Um, and I saw, I actually went to a talk that he did.
我要查一下，是哪一本？但那也是拉里·尼文在 70 年代写的《环形世界》。哦，好的。嗯，我其实去听过他的一次演讲。
Um, and he's continuing to write books in the ring world series, even as early, like as recently as a year or two ago oh wow so that's kind of crazy uh jerry brunel also writes um to still to now i think have you ever written a short story or a book or anything when i was in high school for school assignments yeah Yeah, same here. Okay. I haven't ever written anything.
嗯，他还在继续写《环形世界》系列的书，甚至就在一两年前。哦，哇，这太疯狂了。杰里·普内尔也还在写。你写过短篇小说或书吗？我在高中时为了学校作业写过。是的，我也是。好吧，我从来没写过什么。
I have a friend who is an English major and she writes short stories. They actually have, kind of like we have hackathons. They have hackathons, basically, where it's like, write a book in a month. And she just writes eight hours a day
我有一个朋友是英语专业的，她写短篇小说。他们其实有类似我们黑客马拉松的活动。他们有黑客马拉松，基本上就是在一个月内写一本书。她每天写八个小时，
or something ridiculous. All right. Time for tool of the show. Tool of the show. My tool of the show is OpenEMU, which is pretty freaking awesome. It's Mac only, which is a shame. But it has an unbelievable UI. So OpenEMU is what's called an emulator front end. And so what that means is, they take a lot of emulators, most emulators have like a command line interface, right? So you can
或者类似荒谬的事情。好了，现在是节目工具环节。节目工具。我的工具是 OpenEMU，它简直太棒了。它只支持 Mac，这很遗憾。但它的用户界面令人难以置信。OpenEMU 是所谓的模拟器前端。这意味着，他们采用了许多模拟器，大多数模拟器都有命令行界面，对吧？所以你可以
just like execute the emulator, you know, they might have a little GUI, if you if you run the emulator is like a little program, it'll pop up a little GUI, usually something just really crappy, where you open a file like zsnes, right had that pop up a little GUI usually something just really crappy where you open a file like zsnes right had that like really ghetto looking GUI but if you were to like run zsnes with a you know arguments you can actually like launch zsnes and go straight to a game right so people have created front ends where the whole point is to give you a better user interface and give you a window into your library of cartridges that you legally own. So this OpenEMU is pretty epic.
直接执行模拟器，它们可能有一个小 GUI，如果你运行模拟器作为一个小程序，它会弹出一个小 GUI，通常是一些非常烂的东西，你打开一个文件，比如 ZSNES，对吧，它有一个弹出的小 GUI，通常是一些非常烂的东西，你打开一个文件，比如 ZSNES，对吧，它有那个看起来很简陋的 GUI。但如果你用参数运行 ZSNES，你实际上可以直接启动 ZSNES 并直接进入游戏。所以人们创建了前端，其全部意义在于为你提供更好的用户界面，并为你提供一个窗口来查看你合法拥有的卡带库。所以这个 OpenEMU 非常史诗级。
So you can see from the screenshot, if you're watching the Twitch stream, it kind of looks like iTunes. pretty epic so you can see from the screenshot if you're watching the twitch stream um like this it kind of looks like itunes um it has this like it actually downloads the cover art for you so there must be some must be some open source or some repository where where they can get these all these covers so they have covers for almost everything and uh downloads the cover art it like analyzes the the you know the hash of the of the rom to figure out like what game it is and then it like corrects the file name the title all that stuff so like it's like itunes like legit like you know figures out the artist you know in this case the development you just use legit and emulation in in the sentence so this is this is pretty epic um pretty pretty exciting they even have a cool website no um and
你可以从截图中看到，如果你在看 Twitch 直播，它看起来有点像 iTunes。非常史诗级，你可以从截图中看到，如果你在看 Twitch 直播，它看起来有点像 iTunes。它实际上会为你下载封面艺术，所以一定有一些开源或存储库，他们可以从那里获取所有这些封面。所以他们几乎拥有所有东西的封面，而且它会下载封面艺术，它会分析 ROM 的哈希值来确定是什么游戏，然后它会纠正文件名、标题等等。所以它就像 iTunes，合法地找出艺术家，在这种情况下是开发商。你刚才在句子中用了“合法”和“模拟”，所以这非常史诗级，非常令人兴奋。他们甚至有一个很酷的网站，不，而且
no what they their website has my new my newest pet peeve is the equivalent of the blink tag where you scroll down and stuff animates as you're scrolling like you don't like that oh i hate that really oh so much i think it's so good no ah why i think it looks awesome no it's awful i think it's like uh it's like you should feel bad if you write it's like a movie that you can watch over and over again no the i'm watching the apple announcement i'm watching like the this is the new ipad or the new iphone they did a website like this and it's just awful so confusing it's confusing there's one direction well so this one actually doesn't scroll back until you scroll off screen that's even weirder that is weird i like it when it's like i can i can sort of relive the moment
不，他们的网站有我最新的宠物怨念，相当于 blink 标签，当你向下滚动时，东西会随着你的滚动而动画化。你不喜欢那样吗？哦，我讨厌那个。真的吗？哦，太讨厌了。我觉得它很好。不，啊，为什么？我觉得它看起来很棒。不，它太糟糕了。我觉得这就像……如果你写这种东西，你应该感到羞愧。这就像一部你可以一遍又一遍观看的电影。不，我正在看苹果的发布会，我正在看，这是新的 iPad 或新的 iPhone，他们做了一个这样的网站，简直太糟糕了。太令人困惑了，它令人困惑。只有一个方向。好吧，所以这个实际上在你滚动出屏幕之前不会滚回去，那更奇怪。那确实很奇怪。我喜欢那种我可以重温那一刻的感觉。
yeah yeah um we had a website or news article like last time and after i talked about i tried to like actually like read the whole thing and i had to give up because it was like doing this i think it was coin coin did this really badly actually um well it's my new pet peeve uh yeah okay so i love your pet peeve but anyways so wait no you hate my pet peeve no um no i love your pet peeve the thing that you have a pet peeve that's not my pet peeve okay anyways um it's pretty cool another thing that these guys get right which is genius is like one of these obvious like can't believe i didn't think of that kind of things is they basically they bought one of you know the most common joysticks like if you just go on logitech and try and buy a pc joystick and also like the xbox controller and like they just bought all of these and then for each one they configured it how it should be and then if you
是的，是的。嗯，我们上次有一个网站或新闻文章，在我谈论它之后，我试着读完整篇文章，但我不得不放弃，因为它一直在做这个。我想是 Coin 做的，真的很糟糕。好吧，这是我新的宠物怨念。是的，好吧，所以我喜欢你的宠物怨念，但无论如何，等等，不，你讨厌我的宠物怨念。不，不，我喜欢你的宠物怨念，你有宠物怨念这件事本身不是我的宠物怨念。好吧，无论如何，它很酷。这些家伙做对的另一件事，简直是天才，就像那种显而易见、不敢相信我没想到的事情，他们基本上买了最常见的操纵杆之一，比如如果你去罗技买一个 PC 操纵杆，还有 Xbox 控制器，他们买了所有这些，然后为每一个都配置了它应该有的样子，然后如果你
plug in like a logitech or xbox controller you don't have to set all the little keys, like say, oh, this is the up arrow on my controller, because they've done it for a lot of the popular controllers. That's a clever little add-on. It's pretty cool. Check it out if you're into that. So that's my tool of the show. Mine is mint.com.
插入罗技或 Xbox 控制器，你不需要设置所有的小按键，比如，哦，这是我控制器上的向上箭头，因为他们已经为许多流行的控制器做好了。这是一个聪明的小插件。它很酷。如果你喜欢这个，去看看吧。这就是我的节目工具。我的是 Mint.com。
I'm sure we've talked about it before, but I don't care, because I was just thinking the other day how how awesome it is okay so if you're not using my mint.com is completely broken it's still it uh i just haven't been keeping up to date i need to like reconnect it to my accounts and everything so yeah i i think this is one of those things where it actually used to work better than it does now. Oh, really? Sort of, because I think, as far as I can tell, what happens is the credit card companies have their own solutions, right, and their own things they want to go. And so they're not super keen on the idea of, like, making sure to stay compatible with Mint.com every change. Oh, I see. with mint.com every change oh and so even though like you know as a customer i want them to stay
我相信我们以前谈过它，但我不在乎，因为我前几天还在想它有多棒。好吧，如果你没在用，Mint.com 完全坏了。它还在，我只是没跟上更新，我需要把它重新连接到我的账户等等。所以，是的，我认为这是那种过去比现在好用的东西之一。哦，真的吗？某种程度上，因为我认为，据我所知，发生的事情是信用卡公司有他们自己的解决方案，对吧，他们有他们想做的事情。所以他们不太热衷于确保与 Mint.com 保持兼容，每次更新都要……哦，我明白了。与 Mint.com 每次更新。哦，所以即使作为客户，我希望他们保持
compatible you know they want to force me into using like you know oh american express use the american my your american express app on your phone it's like well i want to use mint because i could just have one yeah right anyways so i do occasionally there's periods where stuff stops working and then they eventually fix it. Okay. So I just bear through the pain. But when it works, it works really beautiful, which is like I don't have to go to like my bank and my credit card and other stuff to like cease. I just go to Mint and it tells me like here's where you're at. And they get the graphics right where I can like go and say how I've been doing over the last year.
兼容，他们想强迫我使用，比如，哦，美国运通，使用你的美国运通手机应用。这就像，好吧，我想用 Mint，因为我可以只用一个。是的，没错。无论如何，偶尔会有东西停止工作，然后他们最终会修复它。好的。所以我只是忍受痛苦。但当它工作时，它工作得非常漂亮，比如我不必去我的银行和信用卡和其他地方查看。我只是去 Mint，它告诉我你现在的状况。而且他们的图表做得很好，我可以去查看过去一年我做得怎么样。
What has my trajectory been? Have I been spending more than I make, making more than I spend? What are the months where I spend the most? Why? All that kind of analysis, which for me, I don't stick to a fully allocated budget where it's like you have $10 to spend on coffee know coffee houses yeah that never makes sense it's usually i think what you're doing you know but i don't but what i do like is keeping tabs on where i'm spending money and like right thinking about it like hey you know that's a lot of money i should cut back on that because yeah it's amdahl's law right you get the biggest return for minimizing the biggest expense right yeah that and also just
我的轨迹是什么？我花的比赚的多吗？赚的比花的多吗？我花钱最多的月份是哪些？为什么？所有这些分析，对我来说，我不坚持一个完全分配的预算，比如你每个月有 10 美元买咖啡，咖啡馆，是的，那从来没有意义。通常我认为你在做什么，你知道，但我确实喜欢记录我把钱花在哪里，比如思考它，嘿，你知道那是一大笔钱，我应该削减开支，因为是的，这是阿姆达尔定律，对吧？你通过最小化最大的开支获得最大的回报，对吧？是的，那还有
like the fact that when you look at it in one place you say oh that's kind of a lot like i can i should cut that back and then i i have been successful in doing it that and i don't the hassle of a budget never made me stick to it yeah that's i'm exactly in the same boat right like uh like there's a few things like think about it right like cable and phone right away that's, you know, and think about it, right? Like, cable and phone. Right away, that's, like, you know, it could be up to $200 for some people, right? A month. Yep.
事实上，当你把它放在一个地方看时，你会说，哦，那有点多，我应该削减它，然后我成功地做到了。我从来没有被预算的麻烦所困扰。是的，我和你完全一样。比如，想想看，有线电视和电话，马上，那就是，你知道，对某些人来说可能高达 200 美元，对吧？一个月。是的。
That is absolutely gigantic. I mean, that dwarfs your gas bill. Well, maybe, depending on how much you drive. Well, that definitely dwarfs your coffee bill. But, yeah, I mean, you're absolutely right that there's, like, a handful of things that people spend just an incredible amount of money on. And reducing even just a little bit there can make a huge difference. Like, I was finally able to get my family off text messaging. And, I mean, that's significant.
那绝对是巨大的。我的意思是，那让你的汽油费相形见绌。嗯，也许吧，取决于你开多少车。嗯，那绝对让你的咖啡费相形见绌。但是，是的，我的意思是，你是绝对正确的，有少数几样东西人们花掉了一大笔钱。即使在那里减少一点点也能产生巨大的差异。比如，我终于能够让我的家人停止使用短信了。我的意思是，那很显著。
I mean, it saved us, like, $20 a month, you know. I mean, it's, like, you know know probably more than we spend in gas because I take the bus I take the shuttle to work so uh yeah we probably saved almost our entire gas bill just in getting rid of SMS nice yeah and I so I like it for you looking at the site and like I said the trends to like wow I spend how much and on clothes or whatever like oh that's kind of crazy and like your clothes spending is out of control it's like i know like which is kind of obvious i guess but like november and december we end up buying you know christmas gifts or whatever for family and so then like
我的意思是，它每个月为我们节省了 20 美元，你知道。我的意思是，这可能比我们花在汽油上的钱还多，因为我坐公交车，我坐班车上班。所以，是的，我们可能仅仅通过摆脱短信就节省了几乎全部的汽油费。不错。是的，所以我喜欢它，因为你可以查看网站和趋势，比如，哇，我在衣服或其他东西上花了多少钱，比如，哦，那太疯狂了，你的服装支出失控了。这就像，我知道，这很明显，我想，但比如 11 月和 12 月，我们最终会为家人购买圣诞礼物或其他东西，所以
spending in november and december are typically high right and so like okay like i know like to be careful the next couple months and like stuff not related to christmas spending that i can wait because i know christmas spending is going to be high yeah don't buy that shirt okay anyways you actually is clothes a large expense for you no i was just trying to say something generic and not very personal i'm just giving you a hard time that's my pet peeve is uh is when i'm not giving patrick are you saying i don't look stylish and handsome enough to uh be spending a lot on my clothes i think you look so handsome that i demanded you show your face in the podcast in the stream sim d all right so right off the top yeah so, so SimD, right off the bat, we'll spoil it for everyone.
11 月和 12 月的支出通常很高，所以，好吧，我知道在接下来的几个月里要小心，比如那些与圣诞支出无关的东西，我可以等，因为我知道圣诞支出会很高。是的，别买那件衬衫。好吧，无论如何，衣服对你来说是一笔大开支吗？不，我只是想说一些通用的、不那么私人的东西。我只是在为难你。这是我的宠物怨念，当我没有给帕特里克……你是说我不够时尚和帅气，所以不能在衣服上花很多钱吗？我觉得你很帅，所以我要求你在直播的播客中露脸。SIMD，好的，就在最上面。是的，所以，SIMD，开门见山，我们给每个人剧透一下。
Single instruction, multiple data. And so what that means is, you know, like a canonical example is, you know, I have three lists. I have two lists with a bunch of numbers in them. And then I have a third list that i want to hold the sum of the numbers of the first two lists but i want to be like an element wise sum so i take the first element of the two lists add them up take the second element of the two lists add them up and it's like the same exact instruction right so you could you know like you could as a like if you could just have the assembly code or what have you say you know put the first item in a register you know put the first item from both lists and two registers add
单指令多数据。这意味着，你知道，一个典型的例子是，我有三个列表。我有两个列表，里面有一堆数字。然后我有第三个列表，我想保存前两个列表数字的和，但我想要一个逐元素的和。所以我取两个列表的第一个元素，把它们加起来，取两个列表的第二个元素，把它们加起来，这就像完全相同的指令，对吧？所以你可以，你知道，你可以作为一个，比如，如果你可以只有汇编代码或什么的，说，你知道，把第一个项目放在一个寄存器里，你知道，把两个列表的第一个项目放在两个寄存器里，加
them up put that in the third list do it again do it again do it again do it again right but if you're doing something like so obvious like the same exact operation but you're just doing it on different spots of the of the memory then you can do what's called single instruction multiple data where you say something like take these ten things and add them together but because you're doing exactly the same thing to all ten you don't have to repeat yourself you just say do it to all ten and it just kind of magically works. So the way this – what this buys you is parallelism, as Jason described.
起来，把那个放在第三个列表里，再做一次，再做一次，再做一次，再做一次，对吧？但如果你在做一些非常明显的事情，比如完全相同的操作，但你只是在内存的不同位置做，那么你可以做所谓的“单指令多数据”，你说类似“取这十个东西并把它们加在一起”，但因为你对所有十个东西做完全相同的事情，你不需要重复自己，你只需要说“对所有十个做”，它就神奇地起作用了。所以这为你带来的是并行性，正如 Jason 所描述的那样。
So things go faster, and that's always a good thing. People like faster. And the way it works is in the processor, you can think about – so like as Jason was saying, you're adding these element-wise, all these things in a list. So if you have each element in the list is 8 bits wide, and you have a 64-bit ALU, Arithmetic Logic Unit, so you have the ability to add 64-bit numbers, you could add two 64-bit numbers, or you could add eight 8-bit numbers.
所以事情变得更快了，这总是一件好事。人们喜欢更快。它的工作原理是在处理器中，你可以考虑——正如 Jason 所说的，你正在逐元素地添加列表中的所有这些东西。所以如果列表中的每个元素是 8 位宽，而你有一个 64 位 ALU（算术逻辑单元），所以你有能力添加 64 位数字，你可以添加两个 64 位数字，或者你可以添加八个 8 位数字。
And the only difference is you need to prevent the carry between each 8 bit number uh so typically there's a carry bit where you know if two numbers are one it has in binary it has to carry to the next digit oh so you need to be able to turn that off on the boundaries so you have eight gotcha with carries then you have a boundary between eight bits that has the ability to either carry or not depending on if it's a normal 64-bit ad or a simd 64-bit ad and when you're doing a simd 64-bit ad on each of the eight boundaries or seven boundaries each of the seven boundaries um you disable the carry bits and so what happens is then when you add to 64-bit numbers you're actually adding eight 8-bit numbers and storing the
唯一的区别是你需要防止每个 8 位数字之间的进位。所以通常有一个进位位，你知道，如果两个数字是 1，在二进制中它必须进位到下一位。哦，所以你需要能够在边界上关闭它。所以你有八个，明白了，带有进位，然后你在 8 位之间有一个边界，它有能力根据它是正常的 64 位加法还是 SIMD 64 位加法来决定进位或不进位。当你对八个边界中的每一个或七个边界中的每一个进行 SIMD 64 位加法时，你禁用了进位位，所以发生的情况是，当你添加两个 64 位数字时，你实际上是在添加八个 8 位数字并存储
result with no carries between them and so that allows you to do instead of saying normally you would have to move an 8-bit number into the 64-bit register move another 8-bit number into the 64-bit register add the to store them in a 64-bit register and then write that out to memory. But all the rest of that 50, well, 50. It's so late at night, 56. Oh, man, it's too late at night. 56 bits are all just going to be zero.
结果，它们之间没有进位。所以这允许你这样做，而不是说通常你必须把一个 8 位数字移动到 64 位寄存器中，把另一个 8 位数字移动到 64 位寄存器中，把它们加起来存储在一个 64 位寄存器中，然后把它写回内存。但剩下的那 50，嗯，50。现在太晚了，56。哦，天哪，现在太晚了。56 位都只是零。
So you're adding zero plus zero plus zero plus, you know, 56 times. And that's just a waste. So that's how SIMD buys you an advantage. I always thought that i mean so correct me if i'm wrong like but and i'm probably wrong but what what is i always thought that it was a separate processor than the alu like i thought it was sometimes not it is these are all this is like at a fundamental architectural like they share these similarities but sometimes just like floating point unit can be a separate thing or inline.
所以你在加零加零加零，你知道，56 次。那只是浪费。所以这就是 SIMD 如何为你带来优势。我一直以为，我的意思是，纠正我如果我错了，但我可能错了，但我一直以为它是一个独立于 ALU 的处理器，比如我以为它有时不是，它是，这些都是，这就像在根本的架构上，它们共享这些相似之处，但有时就像浮点单元可以是一个独立的东西或内联的。
Like it just is an architectural decision. Gotcha. Okay, that makes sense. And so what it turns out is normally the instruction set will support like 64-bit integers, but they'll have two special 128-bit registers and corresponding ALU with this option. But they'll have the ability to do it on 32-bit boundaries, 64-bit boundaries, you know, various divisions. Because you may not always, you want to do as many as possible. But typically, like, the 8-bit boundary example I gave wouldn't be very useful.
这只是一个架构决定。明白了。好的，这说得通。所以事实证明，通常指令集会支持 64 位整数，但它们会有两个特殊的 128 位寄存器和带有此选项的相应 ALU。但它们将有能力在 32 位边界、64 位边界、你知道，各种划分上做到这一点。因为你可能并不总是，你想要尽可能多地做。但通常，比如，我给出的 8 位边界例子不会很有用。
People don't want to only add 8-bits at a time. So typically, you'd have, like, a 32-bit boundary a 64-bit boundary 128-bit boundary for 256-bit wide simd would be very common gotcha um so if it's 256-bit wide simd then you can do uh what eight eight you can add eight numbers in one instruction okay got it but so typically i think most of it so we'll get to this in a minute a lot of this is used for graphics and so you're typically dealing with 32-bit numbers and you want to do we'll get to why later for 32-bit numbers and so it's very common to have 128-bit oh okay but like i said these are all just like it it's a concept right so i'm sure every variation has been done at some point.
人们不想一次只加 8 位。所以通常，你会有一个 32 位边界、64 位边界、128 位边界，对于 256 位宽的 SIMD 会非常常见。明白了。所以如果是 256 位宽的 SIMD，那么你可以做，嗯，八个，你可以用一条指令添加八个数字。好的，明白了。但通常我认为大部分，所以我们一会儿会谈到这个，大部分是用于图形的，所以你通常处理的是 32 位数字，你想做，我们稍后会谈到为什么是 32 位数字，所以拥有 128 位是非常常见的。哦，好的。但正如我所说，这些都只是一个概念，对吧？所以我相信每种变体在某个时候都被做过。
Yeah, right. And that's kind of architecturally how it works. And like I said, the ALU is for addition, but it would also be the same supported operations for division, multiplication, reciprocals, bit masking. You know, all those kinds of things would typically be supported in a similar fashion. Gotcha. We've previously talked a little bit about GPU programming. I think we did an episode on CUDA. And a difference between this and the way GPUs work
是的，没错。这就是架构上的工作方式。正如我所说，ALU 是用于加法的，但它也将是除法、乘法、倒数、位掩码的相同支持操作。你知道，所有这些类型的事情通常都会以类似的方式得到支持。明白了。我们之前谈过一点 GPU 编程。我想我们做过一期关于 CUDA 的节目。这与 GPU 工作方式的区别
is that in SIMD, if you have a branching logic statement, if statements, even though the GPU doesn't handle that great, it has support for handling it because each thing is running on its own minimally functional processor, but it is its own processor.
在于，在 SIMD 中，如果你有一个分支逻辑语句，if 语句，即使 GPU 处理得不是很好，它也有支持处理它的能力，因为每个东西都在它自己的最小功能处理器上运行，但它是它自己的处理器。
So they can be doing slightly different things. You just lose some efficiency. But with SIMD instructions, you actually cannot. So you, like we said, you're treating, it becomes 128-bit number, a 256-bit number, and it just has these weird boundaries within it. But you're responsible for shuffling the data into that number and back out and so you can't make decisions like if the second item is this and at the same time if the third item is this like you would have to do those sequentially
所以它们可以做稍微不同的事情。你只是失去了一些效率。但使用 SIMD 指令，你实际上不能。所以你，就像我们说的，你正在处理，它变成了一个 128 位数字，一个 256 位数字，它只是在其中有这些奇怪的边界。但你有责任把数据洗牌到那个数字里再洗出来，所以你不能做决定，比如如果第二个项目是这个，同时如果第三个项目是这个，你必须按顺序做这些。
gotcha and so that's a that's a big difference um but the other difference is it's cheaper from a silicon perspective to implement this right so as opposed to a whole swarm of g specialized gpu processors um some of the common ones what about like performance like is it the same i mean is it worse than a gpu or different oh it's different depends on what you want to do right like it they're all different so the gpu has advantages, but it's more costly, right? So you're not going to typically... It's done in a different way. So like in a low-power, small processor,
明白了，所以这是一个很大的区别。嗯，但另一个区别是，从硅片角度来看，实现这个更便宜，对吧？所以与一大群专门的 GPU 处理器相比，一些常见的，性能怎么样？我的意思是，它比 GPU 差还是不同？哦，它不同，取决于你想做什么，对吧？就像它们都不同，所以 GPU 有优势，但它成本更高，对吧？所以你通常不会……它是以不同的方式完成的。所以就像在低功耗、小处理器中，
there's no way you'll ever have a whole bunch of GPU cores. Gotcha. Because they were talking at one time about like Intel wanted to put a gpu on the on die motherboard yeah yeah oh yeah yeah on the actual core yeah yeah um so you still have to typically you would still want different memory because the access patterns are different so you'd want to move back and forth between it anyways it gets complicated oh i see they're just okay two different tools gotcha okay and so the things you may have heard of before which are implementations of simd specifically pennium if you remember way back you had heard of mmx processors i think this is
你永远不可能拥有一大堆 GPU 核心。明白了。因为他们曾经谈论过英特尔想把 GPU 放在芯片主板上，是的，是的，哦，是的，是的，在实际的核心上，是的，是的。嗯，所以你通常仍然想要不同的内存，因为访问模式不同，所以无论如何你都想在它们之间来回移动。这变得很复杂。哦，我明白了，它们只是，好的，两个不同的工具。明白了，好的。所以你以前可能听说过的东西，它们是 SIMD 的实现，特别是 Pentium，如果你记得很久以前，你听说过 MMX 处理器，我想这是
multimedia extensions and so okay you'll often hear of these as like some sort of extension because what it's saying is you have the normal instruction set, then there's some supported extension to that instruction set which allows for this extra-wide operations to take place. Also SSE. So SSE was Simultaneous SIMD Execution or Extension, one of those. Something like that. So those are penny ones.
多媒体扩展，所以好的，你经常会听到这些作为某种扩展，因为它的意思是你有正常的指令集，然后对该指令集有一些支持的扩展，允许进行这些超宽操作。还有 SSE。所以 SSE 是 Simultaneous SIMD Execution 或 Extension，其中之一。类似的东西。所以那些是 Pentium 的。
So SSE, SSE2. So these are like penny three penny fours yeah so um you'll have heard of those before and then for arm processor getting powerful now or getting common now and arm processors also have their version of simd which is called neon um and you'll hear these a lot with multimedia. And the reason why is because, like I was saying, so graphics processing, video codecs, audio, this kind of thing, because these have a lot of, I don't know the exact right word, blind operations where you just want to blindly apply the same mathematical function to a lot of data all at the same time. Okay. And so these extensions are really good at speeding those things up. And you can get, like we were saying,
所以 SSE，SSE2。所以这些就像 Pentium 3，Pentium 4，是的。所以，嗯，你以前听说过这些，然后对于 ARM 处理器，现在变得强大或变得普遍，ARM 处理器也有它们的 SIMD 版本，叫做 NEON，你会经常在多媒体中听到这些。原因是因为，就像我说的，所以图形处理、视频编解码器、音频，这种东西，因为这些有很多，我不知道确切的词，盲目操作，你只是想盲目地将相同的数学函数同时应用于大量数据。好的。所以这些扩展在加速这些事情方面非常擅长。而且你可以得到，就像我们说的，
so if you can do four or eight 32-bit instructions at one time, that's like a 4x or 8x speedup for that portion of the code. Gotcha. So some examples that we want to do, we talked about you could add two numbers in a list, you could do cross products, you could do dot products, you could do averaging. So averaging would be a little bit where you start to get into some trickiness, right?
所以如果你能一次做四个或八个 32 位指令，那对于那部分代码来说就是 4 倍或 8 倍的加速。明白了。所以我们想做的一些例子，我们谈到你可以添加列表中的两个数字，你可以做叉积，你可以做点积，你可以做平均。所以平均会有一点点，你开始进入一些棘手的地方，对吧？
So for averaging, if you have, let's say, four 32-bit numbers you can do at a time and you have 16 items in your list, you'd want to add two sets of four twice. So you have four and four, four four and four and you do them simultaneously and then you'd have yeah two sets of four resultant then you'd add those two sets so now you've done three operations this is really hard to describe over only becomes like a pair it's like a pyramid exactly right so you'd have now you have done three operations then you will no longer be able to use simd really uh because you need to add that one last remaining set of four together and then divide by the total number of elements. But you
所以对于平均，如果你有，假设一次可以做四个 32 位数字，而你的列表中有 16 个项目，你会想把四组加两次。所以你有四和四，四、四和四，你同时做它们，然后你会有，是的，两组四个结果，然后你会把那两组加起来，所以现在你做了三次操作。这很难描述，它只变成了一对，就像一个金字塔，完全正确。所以你现在已经做了三次操作，然后你将无法真正使用 SIMD，因为你需要把最后剩下的一组四个加在一起，然后除以元素的总数。但你
can see how you, depending on how many operations you have, you can get a very large speed up. Yeah, right. So just a shout out to Pano DK, who just subscribed to or followed the stream. So thanks. Nice. Oh, he also had a suggestion about earlier. We have our first follower, which is pretty awesome. So another one you'll hear a lot is a 4x4 matrix multiply. And so in graphics, this is because you have typically three-dimensional rotation matrices
可以看到你，取决于你有多少操作，你可以获得非常大的加速。是的，没错。所以向 Pano DK 致敬，他刚刚订阅或关注了直播。所以谢谢。不错。哦，他之前也有一个建议。我们有了第一个关注者，这太棒了。所以另一个你会经常听到的是 4x4 矩阵乘法。所以，在图形学中，这是因为你通常有三维旋转矩阵
and coordinates that are stored for triangles and various, and you store the fourth one to account for some mathematical quirk. I don't know if we ever talked about that before. Yeah, like the quaternions, right? Yeah. So you typically do a four-by-four matrix. I feel like we talked about it briefly,
和为三角形存储的坐标，以及各种，你存储第四个来解释一些数学怪癖。我不知道我们以前是否谈过这个。是的，就像四元数，对吧？是的。所以你通常做一个 4x4 矩阵。我觉得我们简要谈过它，
but like, yeah, we didn't go into a lot of detail. But let's just say that there's some funky math you can do using 4D math, which has no relationship to what you're actually doing, but just mathematically gives you some niceties. Is that like a one-liner that can kind of wrap it up? And so I appreciate this. So this 4x4 matrix multiply with pretty much all these kind of SIMD instructions that works really well and gives you big speed up because you're doing that over and over and over again because you're doing coordinate transform after coordinate transform
但，是的，我们没有深入细节。但我们只说，你可以使用 4D 数学做一些时髦的数学，这与你实际在做的事情没有关系，但只是在数学上给你一些好处。那是一个可以总结它的单行代码吗？所以我很欣赏这一点。所以这个 4x4 矩阵乘法，几乎所有这些 SIMD 指令都工作得很好，并给你很大的加速，因为你一遍又一遍地做，因为你在做坐标变换，坐标变换之后
after coordinate yeah yeah just to put this in perspective right like if you're doing let's say you're making a video game right and uh um you have some dude you know like grand theft auto style and he's running and he's holding like two uzzi's like John Woo like dual wielding Uzi's right so now it's like you want to render you know a bullet coming out of the Uzi so you need to do a transformation to go from the universe to the camera a transformation to go from the camera to the person you're looking at that's another you know matrix multiply that transformation to go from that person's frame of reference to his hand one to go from the hand to the barrel of the gun and another one to the count from the barrel of the gun out to the bullet right
之后坐标，是的，是的，只是为了把这个放在视角里，对吧？比如如果你正在做，假设你正在制作一个视频游戏，然后，嗯，你有一些家伙，你知道，像《侠盗猎车手》风格，他在跑，他拿着像吴宇森电影里那样的两把乌兹冲锋枪，双持乌兹，对吧？所以现在就像你想渲染，你知道，一颗子弹从乌兹里出来，所以你需要做一个变换，从宇宙到相机，一个变换，从相机到你正在看的人，那是另一个，你知道，矩阵乘法，那个变换，从那个人的参考系到他的手，一个从手到枪管，另一个从枪管到子弹，对吧？
you know like the spin of the bullet yeah they have to do another one for that for the spin right so you have to do like 10 of these four by four matrix multiplies just to like know where the bullet is like you haven't even drawn the bullet if you want to draw the little triangles of the bullet now you have to do one of those for each of those triangles right so you're doing a lot of them so yeah so any speed and this is why like i was saying before these typically have names like associated with multimedia or graphics is because that's where you'll see a lot of the use same thing like audio processing you know you'll want to apply some filter and typically at every point in the signal you want to look at the surrounding few points so now what you basically end up with is like you shift an element in you apply the same operations you shift the next
你知道，比如子弹的旋转，是的，他们必须为此再做一个，为了旋转，对吧？所以你必须做大约10次这种4x4矩阵乘法，仅仅是为了知道子弹在哪里，就像你甚至还没画出子弹一样。如果你想画出子弹的小三角形，现在你必须为每一个三角形做一次，对吧？所以你做了很多次。所以是的，任何速度，这就是为什么像我之前说的，这些通常有与多媒体或图形相关的名字，因为那是你会看到大量使用的地方。同样的事情，比如音频处理，你知道，你会想要应用一些过滤器，通常在信号的每一点，你都想看看周围的几个点。所以现在你基本上得到的是，你移入一个元素，应用相同的操作，你移入下一个
element in you apply the same operations you just keep doing that over and over again and this is where you can really get the kind of naive big speed ups because it's really really well suited gotcha makes sense um but this takes a lot of like you know hand power and i so i've written in several of these simd languages they're not called languages simd styles and almost extensions or extensions sure and what it amounts to is you're writing assembly code like you're not but you are because you basically need to worry about everything like i need to load up the special registers with data exactly arranged how i need it then i need to do specifically like these low-level operations then i need to get the data back out these are the kinds of things you typically worry about when
元素，应用相同的操作，你只是不断地重复这样做。这就是你真正可以获得那种天真的巨大速度提升的地方，因为它非常非常适合。明白了，有道理。嗯，但这需要很多，你知道，手工操作。我写过几种这样的SIMD语言，它们不叫语言，叫SIMD风格，几乎是扩展，或者说是扩展，当然。它相当于你在写汇编代码，你不是在写，但你确实是在写，因为你基本上需要担心所有事情。比如我需要用我需要的数据精确排列来加载特殊的寄存器，然后我需要专门做这些低级操作，然后我需要把数据取出来。这些是你通常担心的事情，当
you're doing like assembly programming and this is very very similar i find it and so you typically kind of wrap it in a function you stick that function somewhere and you call in with uh very nice data classes or objects i pass them in then you do this very kind of horrendous uh but fast uh you know assembly level kind of programming and then you kind of pass it back out in a nice class um oh gotcha that's the way i've got what happens if you get it wrong like i mean it probably doesn't throw an exception right i mean like do you end up with weird numbers or does it like literally well it depends on what you mean by mess it up i well let's say like you uh have some kind of out of bounds or something like that like do you get weird numbers it does the whole typically like wraps or overflows or underflows
你在做汇编编程时，我发现这非常非常相似。所以你通常会把它包装在一个函数里，把那个函数放在某个地方，然后用非常好的数据类或对象调用它。我把它们传进去，然后你做这种非常可怕但快速的汇编级编程，然后你把它传回一个好的类中。哦，明白了，我明白了。如果你弄错了会发生什么？我的意思是，它可能不会抛出异常，对吧？我的意思是，你最终会得到奇怪的数字，还是它会字面上……嗯，这取决于你说的弄错是什么意思。嗯，假设你有一些越界之类的东西，你会得到奇怪的数字吗？它通常会包裹、溢出或下溢
or oh i see yeah it depends but but yes this is the general flow of it um and so obviously that's painful but the good news is uh if you're writing a graphics library and you optimize some part of that, right, people are calling into your API, not to your, they're not going to try to write these SIMD instructions themselves. Yeah, that's true. I mean, for most people out there, you know, you're just relying on, you know, if you're using Unity or whatever for the game engine, you're relying on them to do this stuff for you.
或者……哦，我明白了，是的，这取决于情况，但是的，这就是它的一般流程。显然这很痛苦，但好消息是，如果你正在编写一个图形库并优化了其中的一部分，对吧，人们是在调用你的API，而不是……他们不会尝试自己编写这些SIMD指令。是的，那是真的。我的意思是，对于大多数人来说，你知道，你只是依赖于，如果你正在使用Unity或任何游戏引擎，你依赖他们为你做这些事情。
But actually, you can write code which does SIMD and not even know it. What? I know. That's automatic vectorization, which I actually remember when this came out.
但实际上，你可以编写执行SIMD的代码，甚至不知道自己在做。什么？我知道。那是自动向量化，我实际上记得这是什么时候出来的。
I remember when GCC 4.7 came out, and I just remember my mind being blown because I don't really stay up to date on compilers, like research or anything like that. So I didn't realize that this was an effort. And then all of a sudden it's like, oh, yeah, SIMD for free. It's just like, what? and then all of a sudden it's like oh yeah simd for free it's like what um but yeah basically you know the compiler the guys who write the compiler are very bright um they analyze your
我记得GCC 4.7出来的时候，我记得我的大脑被震撼了，因为我并没有真正跟上编译器研究之类的东西。所以我没有意识到这是一个努力。然后突然间就像，哦，是的，免费的SIMD。就像，什么？然后突然间就像，哦，是的，免费的SIMD，就像，什么？嗯，但是的，基本上，你知道，编写编译器的那些人非常聪明，他们分析你的
for loops and uh if the for loop looks like it's doing something trivial enough that they can you know capture all of the side effects and isolate it, then they will try to replace your code with some decode, which does the same thing but much faster. It's pretty freaking amazing. In GCC 4.7, it was very, very simple. So even like you couldn't use a vector. If you had a vector of floats, the way that like vector, you know, when you actually do the bracket on an STL vector, it passes it through this inline function. And most of the time it does nothing. But if you're
for循环，如果for循环看起来做得足够琐碎，以至于他们可以捕获所有的副作用并将其隔离，那么他们就会尝试用一些代码替换你的代码，这些代码做同样的事情但速度快得多。这真是太棒了。在GCC 4.7中，它非常非常简单。所以即使你不能使用向量。如果你有一个浮点数向量，就像当你真正对STL向量使用括号时，它会通过这个内联函数。大多数时候它什么都不做。但如果你在
in debug mode, it'll like check or do a couple other things and just the fact that that function was in the way caused like all stl vectors to not be supported and you have to you actually had to like create a pointer of the vector and just like you know so you basically have to do it yourself but um but since then it's come a long way and now even if like you know you add two vectors of floats and c++ it'll it'll vectorize it. If it could make some guarantees about the size and things like that. Which is pretty cool. It's also coming to Java. It's not there yet.
调试模式下，它会检查或做一些其他事情，仅仅是那个函数挡路的事实就导致所有的STL向量都不被支持，你必须……你实际上必须创建一个向量的指针，就像……所以你基本上必须自己做。但从那以后，它已经走了很长一段路，现在即使你像……你知道，在C++中添加两个浮点数向量，它也会向量化它。如果它能对大小之类的事情做出一些保证的话。这很酷。它也正在进入Java。还没到那一步。
But that's one of these kind of amazing things. If they build automatic vectorization into the Java virtual machine, then like it's just going to completely change the runtime profile of every Java program ever. I mean, like who knows what's going to happen, right? Yeah, I guess it depends on how they support it. I don't know the exact specifics, but yeah. The other thing like we're saying is like if your library like unity or whatever supports that you get it um also there are of course libraries and i didn't write any down here because i'm not up to date on these right now but where you could get a package of like here's common operations you'd want to do and here they are implemented in ways that are very
但这是一种令人惊奇的事情之一。如果他们将自动向量化构建到Java虚拟机中，那么它将彻底改变每个Java程序的运行时配置文件。我的意思是，谁知道会发生什么，对吧？是的，我想这取决于他们如何支持它。我不知道确切的细节，但是的。另一件事就像我们说的，如果你的库像Unity或任何东西支持它，你就会得到它。当然也有库，我没有在这里写下任何库，因为我现在没有跟上这些，但你可以得到一个包，比如这里是你想要做的常见操作，它们以非常
uh amenable to gcc doing auto vectorization or already have some instructions themselves right so you may have like a wrapper that you pass in st like for instance like jason was saying the stl vectors and c++ didn't work well but you could have someone else well probably and you can find it because i've seen these before have written code that says like you know here's how to do four by four matrix multiply in simd that takes in the vector the stl vector and outputs stl vector right and then yeah exactly it wouldn't be vector it'd be the matrix but um you know takes a matrix and outputs a matrix uh and then it handles the exact massaging into the right form and back out and And that's the only thing that gets you right.
适合GCC进行自动向量化或本身已经有一些指令的方式实现，对吧？所以你可能有一个包装器，你传入STL，比如Jason说的，C++中的STL向量工作得不好，但你可以有其他人……好吧，可能，你可以找到它，因为我以前见过这些，有人写了代码说，你知道，这是如何在SIMD中进行4x4矩阵乘法，它接收向量，STL向量，并输出STL向量，然后……是的，完全正确，它不会是向量，它会是矩阵，但……你知道，接收一个矩阵并输出一个矩阵，然后它处理精确的按摩成正确的形式并输出。这就是唯一能让你得到正确结果的东西。
And those are obviously very useful because it saves you a lot of time. Yeah, one thing that I realized, I just searched on our programming throwdown sort of agendas of all time. We've never talked about BLAS. Do you want to talk about BLAS? I think we should save it for a tool of the... Okay. Why don't you give the high-level? I think we should save it for a tool of the... Okay.
那些显然非常有用，因为它们为你节省了很多时间。是的，我意识到的一件事，我刚刚搜索了我们Programming Throwdown的所有议程。我们从来没有谈论过BLAS。你想谈谈BLAS吗？我想我们应该把它留给工具……好的。你为什么不给个高层概述？我想我们应该把它留给工具……好的。
Why don't you give the high-level summary, and then we'll save it for... So I don't know too much about it. Okay. This is why you're telling me to do it. So BLAS stands for Basic Linear Algebra System. And the idea is, if you want to add two matrices or invert a matrix
你为什么不给个高层概述，然后我们把它留给……所以我对它了解不多。好的。这就是你让我做这件事的原因。所以BLAS代表基本线性代数系统。这个想法是，如果你想添加两个矩阵或反转一个矩阵
or do these kind of mathematical operations that you do in MATLAB or one of these other tools. But you're not using MATLAB, you're using Python or C++ or something. There's this library, this set of libraries that are Blas libraries. And basically, it's what Patrick is saying. These guys have just killed themselves making the most epic matrix inversion code ever, the most epic add two vectors together code ever. And you can just use the BLAS library whenever you want to do one of those things. Yep, and they do some pretty clever stuff.
或者做你在MATLAB或其他工具中做的这些数学运算。但你没有使用MATLAB，你正在使用Python或C++或其他什么。有这个库，这组库是BLAS库。基本上，这就是Patrick所说的。这些人只是为了制作有史以来最史诗般的矩阵反转代码、有史以来最史诗般的两个向量相加代码而累坏了自己。当你想要做这些事情中的任何一件时，你就可以使用BLAS库。是的，他们做了一些非常聪明的事情。
And there's some pretty clever stuff about how to determine like because there's no one right optimal way to do something it's going to vary by your l1 and l2 cache size by your number of hyper threaded cores and by the number of your processor clock speed and like every variable of your computer system. And so I made the mistake one time of compiling Atlas, which is a Blas implementation. I didn't want to use the one that was like built into Ubuntu. And I was like, I'll just build my own.
关于如何确定有一些非常聪明的事情，因为没有一种正确的最佳方法来做某事，它会根据你的L1和L2缓存大小、你的超线程核心数量以及你的处理器时钟速度以及你计算机系统的每个变量而变化。所以我曾经犯过一次编译Atlas的错误，这是一个BLAS实现。我不想使用Ubuntu内置的那个。我就想，我会自己构建一个。
And it took something like eight hours to build. And basically it's like, you know, trying every possible, you know? Yeah. Yeah. It's like trying every possible
它花了大约八个小时来构建。基本上就像，你知道，尝试每一种可能的，你知道？是的。是的。就像尝试每一种可能的
way to build this library just to give you an extra one percent because i don't know well we can talk about later i don't know if they do something intelligent like gradient descent or something or if they just straight out like try every permutation yeah i don't know if they do like something intelligent or if it's just yeah like you said it's a raw parameter suite um but but uh okay but yeah it takes a really really really long time and uh you know most most os's will have it built in and it'll be you know 90 something percent i'm making up a percentage as as fast as it can be but if you compile it yourself they do some really clever things to make it as fast as can be yeah that's right like the one you get from ubuntu isn't made for your machine
构建这个库的方法，只是为了给你额外的一个百分点，因为我不知道……好吧，我们可以稍后再谈，我不知道他们是否做了什么智能的事情，比如梯度下降之类的，或者他们只是直接尝试每一种排列。是的，我不知道他们是否做了什么智能的事情，或者它只是……是的，就像你说的，它是一个原始参数套件。但……好吧，但是的，它需要非常非常非常长的时间，而且……你知道，大多数操作系统都会内置它，它会是……90%多，我编了一个百分比，尽可能快。但如果你自己编译它，他们会做一些非常聪明的事情来让它尽可能快。是的，那是对的，就像你从Ubuntu得到的那个不是为你机器制作的
it's made for you know someone's machine who's building the ubuntu distribution um and so yeah patrick's right like if you build it from scratch after the eight hours you will have something that is like one percent faster but every more maybe yep yeah so everything's on the web now and everybody's trying to do graphics on the web so of course simd is coming to the web yeah that's pretty wild right i mean um so if you're going to do gaming like i said this is all about like doing graphics processing audio processing video processing all things that have a very legitimate reason these days to be done in a web browser um and if you're going to do that you're going to want to take advantage of cindy because it does give like you know it's very conceivable
它是为你……你知道，构建Ubuntu发行版的某人的机器制作的。所以是的，Patrick是对的，如果你从头开始构建它，八小时后你将得到一个快1%的东西，但也许更多。是的，所以现在一切都在网上，每个人都想在网上做图形，所以当然SIMD正在来到网络。是的，这很疯狂，对吧？我的意思是……所以如果你要玩游戏，就像我说的，这都是关于做图形处理、音频处理、视频处理，所有这些在当今网络浏览器中都有非常正当的理由去做。如果你要那样做，你会想要利用SIMD，因为它确实给出了……你知道，这是非常可以想象的
to have like an 8x 10x improvement by implementing this stuff and that's that's big yeah yeah totally i mean uh me and some buddies wrote an emulator um in effectively javascript uh wrote in dart actually we talked about it on one of our shows and uh the emulator you know like rendering all the pixels actually only takes like one or two percent of the time but just executing the nintendo cpu which is just you know like a one megahertz cpu or something ridiculous, takes over 90% of the time. And it's because a lot of times you're doing simple operations, but on the web they're just so painfully slow. And so this SIMD is part of a bigger effort to sort of fix that problem.
通过实现这些东西获得8倍到10倍的改进，这很大。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我和一些伙伴用JavaScript编写了一个模拟器，实际上是用Dart编写的，我们在我们的一个节目中谈论过它。模拟器，你知道，渲染所有像素实际上只占用了1%或2%的时间，但仅仅是执行任天堂CPU，它只是……你知道，像1兆赫的CPU或类似荒谬的东西，占用了超过90%的时间。这是因为很多时候你在做简单的操作，但在网络上它们太慢了，令人痛苦。所以这个SIMD是解决那个问题的一个更大努力的一部分。
Yep, so this SIMD is going to be added to Dart, or so it said a year ago. So I assume it's already there. Oh, man, you're right. This is a year old. I didn't even notice. So you're starting to see a lot of these things. And, again, you will continue as more and more people do stuff in the browser.
是的，所以这个SIMD将被添加到Dart中，或者一年前是这么说的。所以我假设它已经在那里了。天哪，你是对的。这是一年前的。我甚至没注意到。所以你开始看到很多这些东西。而且，再一次，随着越来越多的人在浏览器中做事情，你将继续看到。
Yeah, yeah, totally. I mean, I think that it's only a matter of time before we get like we already have n script in and some of these technologies for taking you know like desktop applications and and basically compiling them for the web and it just kind of magically works but it's still like very early stages um and so this is like sort of building more of that scaffolding so that we can one day get to a place where you could just build something for your desktop and the web and it would just kind of magically do what you want well i think that's a wrap yeah cool um thanks everyone for the for following us on the stream and uh and uh you. We got some good feedback there.
是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我认为我们得到……我们已经有了Nscript和一些用于获取……你知道，像桌面应用程序并基本上为网络编译它们的技术，这只是神奇地工作，但这仍然处于非常早期的阶段。所以这就像是在构建更多的脚手架，以便我们有一天能到达一个地方，你可以只为你的桌面和网络构建一些东西，它就会神奇地做你想要的。好吧，我认为这就是结束。是的，酷。嗯，谢谢大家在流媒体上关注我们，还有……你。我们在那里得到了一些很好的反馈。
Pretty cool. It's been a while since we did a show, but as you can expect with the vacation, I was on vacation, Patrick's on vacation, Thanksgiving's coming up. So it's that time of year where it's hard to find time. Yeah, we'll try to do one before Christmas,
很酷。我们已经有一段时间没做节目了，但正如你所预料的，假期到了，我在度假，Patrick在度假，感恩节快到了。所以这是一年中很难找到时间的时候。是的，我们会尝试在圣诞节前做一个，
but it may end up being January. Yeah, it's possible. but we should be able to grab some time I think we can pull it off but if not we'll see you guys in January but anyways it's always fun to do the show and
但最终可能会是1月。是的，有可能。但我们应该能挤出一些时间，我想我们可以做到，但如果没有，我们会在1月见到你们。但无论如何，做这个节目总是很有趣，而且
you know I'm trying to think do we have anything news worthy like meta anything i didn't look up like how many reviews you have or anything so yeah i don't think we have much meta to say um this is a pretty cool one i definitely want to cover rust um that programming language we got some other requests for languages so we'll be uh covering that we get a lot of actually the majority of our feedback is still on Google+, which is awesome. I mean, we have the Facebook and the Twitter.
你知道，我在想我们有什么值得报道的新闻吗？比如Meta之类的，我没有查你有多少评论之类的。所以是的，我不认为我们有什么Meta要说。这是一个非常酷的节目，我绝对想涵盖Rust，那个编程语言。我们收到了一些其他语言的请求，所以我们将涵盖那个。我们实际上收到了很多……我们的大部分反馈仍然是在Google+上，这太棒了。我的意思是，我们有Facebook和Twitter。
A couple of people asked for those. But still, the majority of the content is happening on the G+, so definitely check that out. And send us email. We read all of them. Sometimes we read them on the show. Sometimes we say your full name and embarrass you. I don't think we've ever read
几个人问过那些。但仍然，大部分内容发生在G+上，所以一定要去看看。给我们发电子邮件。我们读了所有的邮件。有时我们在节目中读它们。有时我们说出你的全名并让你尴尬。我不认为我们曾经读过
anybody's name who told us not to. No, I'm totally kidding. If you want to remain anonymous, we will do that. If you want to remain anonymous with your anonymity... Keep your anonymity in tech
任何告诉我们不要读的人的名字。不，我完全是在开玩笑。如果你想保持匿名，我们会那样做。如果你想用你的匿名性保持匿名……在科技中保持你的匿名性
all right it's late so we're gonna call it a wrap all right see you guys later stopping recording the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，很晚了，所以我们要结束了。好的，回头见。停止录制。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须向Patrick和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。